Ich würde Google nicht unterstellen, dass sie das nicht auch schon getan haben. Es gibt diverse Projekte, wo sie das sehr wohl getan haben und wo sie das maps.
Ja, dann sollten sie es vielleicht mit den anderen Sachen auch mal probieren. Ja, aber warum klappt es sich bei einer fucking Message-App? Jeder Idiot und sein Bruder könnte eine Message-App schreiben.
Na ja, gut, weil das mehr ist als nur Software machen, sondern du musst halt auch mit der Kultur und der Konkurrenz mithalten. Und auch Google ist nicht allmächtig.
Ja, zum Glück.
Ich meine, auch Apple surft mit beständiger Regelmäßigkeit an bestimmten Dingen vorbei. Ja, Ping, all ihre ganzen verzweifelten Versuche, irgendwie Netzwerkkommunikation hinzubekommen. Na gut, ich meine, bei Musik kann man jetzt Apple nicht gerade mangelnden Erfolg vorwerfen. Also das ist, glaube ich, jetzt nicht so der Bereich, wo man sie vorführen kann. Ja, Ping war der Versuch, ein Social Network ohne Social Network zu machen. Ich meine, ich finde, das ehrt sie auch in gewisser Hinsicht, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, da was zu machen, was sie an eigenen Ansprüchen...
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, eine Sache bei Google, die ich gelesen habe, dachte ich so, aha, interessante Idee. Mauseeingabe als Tastatur für Android. Da dachte ich so, hä? Okay, warum nicht? Keine Ahnung, wer das benutzt. Ich finde das immer lustig.
Das wird wieder interessant, weil man ja nur eine Watch hat und da keine Tastatur hat und dann kann man seine Nachrichten morsen. Das wird wieder kommen. Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber...
Niemand morst mehr.
Doch, doch, doch. Und ich habe da von einem...
Niemand ernsthaft das morst mehr.
Huckel hatte das nämlich angebracht, dass niemand mehr morsen würde. Und ein Freund, der auch zu See fährt, hat mir daraufhin eine lange Twitter-Diät geschrieben mit sämtliche militärischen Marien der Welt morsen tatsächlich über Lichtsignale. Immer noch.
Aber nur im Notfall.
Gängige Praxis bei allen Übungsmanövern, sowie einsetzen.
Ja, weil wenn die digitale Kommunikation und der Funk und so weiter zusammenricht, dann müssen sie einen Idioten ins Kalt schicken, der dann mit der Lampe morsen kann. Aber es ist halt nur ein Meganotfall, wenn wirklich nichts anderes mehr geht.
Aber Huckel hatte glaube ich etwas gesagt, man lernt es nicht mehr. Und er hat auch explizit geschrieben, dass er das bei seinem A-Patent große Fahrt machen musste.
Was ist das A-Patent große Fahrt?
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie große Pötte. Ich glaube, du weißt, ich weiß. Er ist schon mal durch den Panama-Kanal auch. Mit einem Schiffchen.
Ich hatte da ja diese Wikipedia-Seite auf, wo drin schon in welchem Militär das noch aktiv benutzt wird. Und da war keins mehr, glaube ich. Aber ich gucke auch nochmal nach. Auf jeden Fall im privaten Bootsverkehr macht man es nicht mehr. Und so wie ich das zumindest jetzt von den Engländern gehört habe, auch nicht bei der Marine. Es gibt halt immer noch so Zeichen, so Fahnenalphabet und so weiter. Das gibt es schon auch immer noch. Aber das ist halt nicht mehr so Kern der Kommunikation.
Das fand ich auch sehr spannend, weil das hast du ja beim Tauchen auch dabei gehabt, dass du eigentlich verpflichtet bist, als Tauchboot die Flagge zu haben, dass du ein Boot bist, was Taucher befördert oder gegebenenfalls auch um dich herum getaucht wird. Das hatten super viele Boote nicht in Costa Rica. Da war ich so leicht irritiert.
Da musst du ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und die Fahne ist schon eigentlich das Billo-Equipment, weil eigentlich brauchst du ja so Bälle und Lichter und so weiter. Aber weil die kleinen Schlauchboote das nicht haben, brauchen die eigentlich nur diese eine Fahne und nicht mal die. Aber es gibt sehr viele Zeichen. Zum Beispiel, wenn Nebel ist, müssen große Schiffe vorne mit der Glocke bimmeln und hinten in Gong dengeln. Und sogar Segelboote sollen eigentlich eine Glocke bei bestimmten Sachen. Niemand hat eine Glocke an Bord. Niemand. Da kannst du in irgendeinem beliebigen Marina latschen und 500 Boote durchgucken und findest was vielleicht.
Dafür gibt es vielleicht die Glocken-App und die Gong-App.
Also es ist ja auch schön, wenn da noch gemorst wird und Leute Spaß dran haben, aber es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich weniger als noch vor 10 oder 20 Jahren. Wo das auch noch im Privatverkehr quasi...
Du willst den Leuten auch nur das Morsen vermiesen.
Das Miesen vermorsen. So, weiter, nächstes Thema.
Frechheit.
Zu wenig Bandbreite.
Das ist eine Frage der Frequenzen.
Ja, aber der Mensch ist ja da. Also du kannst natürlich auch total...
Wer sagt, dass der Mensch morsen muss?
Vielleicht kann die AI einfach morsen. Das ist vielleicht, das ist einfach genug.
Ich lasse morsen.
Ich morse doch nicht selbst.
So sieht's aus.
So, jetzt machen wir die Themenkarte auf.
Weil wir gerade bei Google waren, und ich habe als Thema die Qualität von Dokumentationen von APIs als Rant auf der Liste.
Letty wird warm langsam.
Letty schwingt sich langsam so richtig auf den Rant-Sattel.
Ich habe gerade ein kleines Pet-Projekt, wo ich mir eigentlich nur ein bisschen Vue.js und meine Kenntnisse mit Python so ein bisschen festigen will. Ja, alle sagen Vue.js.
Vue ist da der Unterschied.
Vue, so können sie sich nicht deutlich ausdrücken.
Wie häufig müsste wohl die KI nachfragen, was ich meine? Genau, dieses Vue.js.
Allein schon, weil es ein Pann auf Vue ist. Auf V-I-E-W. Vue spricht man halt auch Vue aus.
Was auch immer. Ich versuche mich gerade zu erinnern, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Das wäre cool, wenn wir alle gleichzeitig unsere Mute-Kasten drücken würden, dass wir dann Tim muten.
Das wäre in der Tat mal eine lustige Anwendung.
Wenn die Mehrheit wegmutet.
Also man hat so 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Man kann sozusagen die anderen muten, aber nur wenn mindestens 3, also die Mehrheit mitmutet, wird jemand sozusagen... Das wird aber dann echt Cybermobbing.
Jetzt legen wir los Letty.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, ich würde schlecht.
Mein Pet-Projekt, wo wollte ich denn hin? Ach ja, genau, ich wollte ranten. Genau, jedenfalls so ein kleines Pet-Projekt, wo ich mir eigentlich nur... Ich finde halt YouTube, ich gucke sehr gerne YouTube und nutze YouTube viel für so Yoga-Videos, weil ich irgendwie täglich Yoga mache. Und ich will mir so ein bisschen so einen Fitnessplan, also Fitnessplan ist das falsche Wort, aber ich will eigentlich so Videos, die ich schon geguckt habe, so klassifizieren, was sie für einen Inhalt haben. So ist das irgendwie besonders anspruchsvoll für die Handgelenke oder ist das besonders Rückendehnen, was auch immer, oder ich kann es machen, wenn ich Migräne habe, was halt auch ein Faktor ab und zu ist. Und YouTube hat irgendwie, oder ich habe diese Funktionalität noch nie gefunden, dass man nicht nur ein Video liken kann oder eine Playlist macht, sondern dem Video noch so ein paar Attribute hinzufügen kann. Und ich habe mir dann halt gedacht, ja okay, warum soll ich mich groß irgendwie mit anderen Diensten rumschlagen oder irgendeinen Scheiß mir angucken, wenn ich es einfach selber coden kann? Und habe halt irgendwie ein bisschen rumgeguckt mit der YouTube-API. Also nur so, um so banale Dinge zu machen, wie eigentlich gib mir doch mal alle Videos von einem bestimmten YouTube-Kanal, damit ich sie mir nur die URLs wegspeichern kann. Ich will mir die YouTube Videos... Wenn du einen Google-Account hast, weil du brauchst dann bei YouTube auch einen Google-Account, um den API-Key zu generieren. Genau. Und... Also brauchst quasi keine Rechte für deinen YouTube-Account sozusagen, weil es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass du mit der API Videos hochlädst und bearbeitest und updaten kannst. Aber so advanced Schnickschnack brauch ich halt gar nicht. Ich brauch eigentlich wirklich mehr oder weniger einmal so eine Art Suche, die mir alle Videos rausholt, damit ich dann danach die Videos nochmal so verteggen kann eigentlich, so ganz banal gesagt.
So...
Das war ein Bild, was heruntergeflogen kam. Das Bild hängt schief, jetzt muss ich noch schief machen.
Ich bin ziemlich gerade am Boden. Ich würd mal sagen, jetzt ist es ausgelabelt.
Tim kann es einfach nicht ertragen, wenn jemand anders rantet und versucht mit allen Mitteln, das zu verhindern.
YouTube, genau. Also ich brauch halt wirklich nur die basic Sachen von einem YouTube-Kanal an Videos, dass ich sie danach bearbeiten kann und mir in einer Datenbank einfach abspeichern. Und da ist mir mal aufgefallen, wie schlecht so Dokumentationen von verschiedenen APIs sind. Sei es, dass sie irgendwie nur so kryptischen Code beinhalten, schlechte Formulierungen, bis hin zu sowas wie... Also dass die API scheinbar auch... Also ich weiß nicht, ich fand dann die API komisch designt, sodass ich mir im Endeffekt gesagt hab, ok, ich brauch gar nicht diesen ganzen Python-Geraffel, den YouTube-Term bereitstellt, dass du sozusagen wie so eine abgefertigte API von denen nutzt, also Package von denen man nutzen kann innerhalb deiner Programmiersprache, sondern ich bau mittlerweile einfach nur alles mit Request, weil das viel einfacher ist, einfach das JSON danach weiter zu bearbeiten. Weißen wir, das erste Mal wirklich so aufgefallen, die stecken so viel scheiß Arbeit in ihre KI. Wie wär's mal, wenn sie ein bisschen ihre Dokumentation ein bisschen aufwäpschen könnten? Na wieso? Du bezahlst Geld, wenn du die API benutzt.
Weil du coole Tools machst, da sollte man mehr Content konzentrieren.
Ja, haben sie ja vielleicht in irgendeinem Side-Track sogar auch erwähnt, aber das Hauptding ist natürlich was anderes.
Das ist ja, also ich finde denn das Gegenbeispiel wiederum ist, ich glaube, das Material Design von Google. Da haben sie eine relativ gute Dokumentation, wie man das auch im Web benutzen kann. Dieses Design, was Google halt auch hat, was so, also auf dem Telefon und auch auf der YouTube-Seite auf jeden Fall häufig genutzt wird. Da wiederum haben sie es irgendwie auf die Reihe bekommen. Aber so diese YouTube-API war fürchterlich, aber immer noch so, dass man sagen konnte, okay, funktioniert irgendwie für einen, kann man ganz gut nutzen. Aber ich bin gestern fast vom Stuhl gefallen. Ich habe mir mal wieder den Arduino rausgepopelt, um mir so ein paar blinkende LEDs für die nächste Critical Mass zu bauen. Critical Mass, wer es nicht kennt, ist so ein Fahrrad-Konvoi, meistens so im letzten Freitag des Monats, wo die Menschen, die vorneweg fahren, die Route bestimmen und man einmal durch die Stadt fährt. Einmal hört es sich nach wenig an.
Das hängt immer von der Stadt ab, oder?
In Berlin kann man wirklich sehr weit fahren. Ich glaube, wir sind das letzte Mal so 30-40 Kilometer unterwegs gewesen durch Berlin. Und bei Nacht ist das halt ganz schön. Da hast du halt die ganzen nervenden Autofahrer, die da rumgestikulieren, dass man nachher endlich von der Straße gehen soll, wie Rüpel. Irgendwas will ich mal was Blinkendes für das Fahrrad haben. Ich hab irgendwie einen LED-Strip, einen Arduino und bei Adafruit gibt es diese Neopixels-Library, die man benutzen kann. Die erleichtert einfach, diese RGB-Strips anzusteuern. Kann ich mal reinpasten. Und es war halt so, du findest Beispielcode, was irgendwie ja nice ist. Aber wenn du damit coden willst, denkst du dir so, ja geil, und jetzt zeig mir mal die Dokumentation, was ich noch alles so machen kann mit dem Ding. Ich hab irgendwie rumgegoogelt und dachte mir, das kann ja nicht sein, dass sie keine Dokumentation haben. Und in irgendeinem Forum weist dann einer auf das C++-Header-File von denen hin. Und ich meinte, ja, da steht doch alles drin, was man braucht.
Das beste Doku ist Topcode.
Ja, aber habt ihr denn einen an der Waffel? Also ich mein, Adafruit sagt irgendwie, sie wollen halt auch Lines ermöglichen, mit den Sachen zu coden. Und ich mein, wenn man vielleicht auch schon mal mit C gearbeitet hat, weiß man vielleicht, wie man es lesen muss. Aber ich stell mir das gerade vor, ich versuch das meinen Studis zu erzeigen. Ich so, hier, steht alles im Hederfall, weißt du ja so vor, was du machen musst. Wenn die mich angucken und sagen, ja gut, tschüss, ich geh dann mal aus dem Kurs raus. Aber das fand ich krass.
Also vor allem das Hederfall lügt halt nicht, weil das ist das, was du benutzt. Weißt du, so Dokus, da weiß ich nicht, ist die jetzt aktuell, ist die hinterher, da hat sich die...
Ah man ey, da war ich so gefrustet. Ich bin jetzt schon so gefrustet, dass ich mir denke, also ich nehme mein, wie heißt das Ding, Arduino mit zur GPN und im Zweifelsfall forke ich dieses Teil, schreib da eine Dokumentation rein und schick den den Pull Request, weil es mich so hart nervt.
Ich fand die mal aus Spaß bei so einem Firmenevent, das war so ein Programmier-Event, da ging es darum, dass jeder mal eine neue Programmiersprache ausprobiert, und dann habe ich da mal Go ausprobiert und dachte mir, alles klar, ich baue jetzt mal einen Slackbot in Go und habe mir die AP angeguckt und war echt sehr positiv überrascht. Alles sofort gefunden.
Ja, ich finde, was ich super gerne nutze, leider nicht mehr von der Firma dahinter maintain wird jetzt ein Community-Projekt, das ist RethinkDB, so eine NoSQL-Datenbank. Früher wurde die halt auch noch von irgendeiner Firma gehört, die ist aber pleite gegangen, wie das wahrscheinlich bei einigen Projekten der Fall sein wird, wo sie dann einfach in der Community weiterleben. Und die haben halt ein superschönes Design und eine super gute Dokumentation, also sowohl API, Dokumentation, Installationshinweise, wie du das benutzt. Also wirklich sehr, sehr gut und ordentlich. Wo ich mir echt denke, so man ey, es geht doch auch echt, wenn man es will.
Na klar geht das, aber das ist halt Aufwand. Also was ich ja ganz schick finde, ist ja, wenn Leute tatsächlich das mit der Rest-API ernst nehmen. Also ich habe ja die These, dass 90% der Rest-APIs nicht wirklich Rest sind, weil es dann immer doch diese Fälle gibt, so ja, aber was ist jetzt in dem Fall? Das passt ja irgendwie doch nicht so richtig. Dann müsste man ja so, okay, komm wir schummeln es jetzt so rein.
Ja, aber mit 90 bist du auch noch tief dabei.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt mal konservativ schätzen. Aber zumindest, für die weitesten Teile gibt es ja so AP-Dokumentationstools. Eins, was ich jetzt beim Kundenprojekt mal hatte einsetzen dürfen, sollen, müssen, war Swagger. Und da kannst du halt deine AP so komplett definieren, inklusive wie die Tokens und so weiter da zu verwenden sind. Und dann kriegst du eine generierte Dokumentation zu allen Faden in deiner AP und kannst in der Doku sogar die Request ausführen. Also du musst dann halt deinen Token sozusagen reinpasten, damit du autorisiert bist. Und dann kannst du sozusagen alle AP-Request einmal sozusagen durchspielen lassen und siehst halt auch die Response direkt im Browser.
Das hat Weather Underground nämlich auch. Also ich bin ja, weiß nicht, also zu Weather Underground gekommen, weil mein damaliges Blackberry ja so zum kotzen war mit der Wetter-App. Und hab das dann aber irgendwann, ja, ist das so ein bisschen eingeschlafen, weil ich halt versucht habe, meine Spezifikation da irgendwie runterzuschreiben. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich es halt echt ein bisschen komplexer denke, als es am Anfang geklungen hat. Aber die Weather Underground API, oh, falscher Slack, hat das nämlich auch, dass man seinen Token da sofort drin hat. Du kannst dir dann Show Response anklicken und du bekommst die komplette Strukturierung von der Response, wie das JSON aufgebaut ist. Da ist auch nicht alles gut drin dokumentiert, aber du kannst es halt sofort ausprobieren. Und das fand ich auch großartig.
Naja, dieses Prinzip, eine Programmiersprache in natural language zu dokumentieren, also quasi die Dokumentation.
Kann ich dir ganz genauso sagen, weil ich habe Grace Hopper vor zwei Wochen persönlich getroffen. Genau, haben wir uns auf dem Kaffee hier im Prenzlberg getroffen.
Wie man Tim den Wind aus den Seelen nimmt.
Ich warte jetzt gerade auf die Erklärung, warum sie das eingeführt hat. Der Begriff wird sicherlich nicht von ihr.
Ja, aber Grace Hopper hat, guckt euch mal, ich haue euch mal einen Link in Slack rein. Ich habe, um nochmal zurückzukommen, ich habe gerade eine Vorlesung, die heißt Coding with Ada, wo es eigentlich nur darum geht, auch so ein bisschen programmieren zu lernen und am Rande wichtige Frauen in der Informatik vorzustellen, mit kurzen Videos oder wie auch immer. Und die erste war natürlich Ada Lovelace. Und danach habe ich Grace Hopper genommen. Und Grace Hopper hat die erste Programmiersprache, die an die englische Sprache angelehnt war, entwickelt. Nämlich? Cobol. Richtig. Und das war der Ansatz, den sie gefahren ist, dass sie gesagt hat, es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir hier mit Nullen und Einzen arbeiten und niemand den Scheiß lesen kann. So, diese wunderbare Dame, die hat es erfunden.
Die ist aber eine ziemlich coole Braut. Also ich habe da auch einiges von ihr gesehen, die ist echt tough. Das ist aber nicht ganz das, was ich meinte.
Sondern?
Ich meinte konkret, also dieses Prinzip des...
Jetzt kommt XML...
.lebende Dokumentation. Da gibt es ja einen Begriff für, der heißt Literate Programming. Und Literate Programming ist halt von Donald Knuth erfunden worden, dieser Begriff, also dieser Paradigm ist sozusagen von ihm. Und da gab es auch schon verschiedene Umsetzungen davon. Das ist jetzt sozusagen nicht neu. Und das also, das ist ja auch selber, aus welchem Jahr ist das? First Published Literate Programming Environment was Web für Tech halt 1981. Und ich habe da auch verschiedene Ansätze zugesehen, auch mit dem Dillon, mit dem ich mal beschäftigt habe. Da gab es auch irgendwie ein schönes Projekt. Und im Prinzip, was Apple jetzt auch macht mit diesem Swift Playground, das geht ja auch in diese Richtung. Dass du quasi deine Dokumentation liest und du kannst in dieser Dokumentation selber den Code ausführen. Heutzutage ist es in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt schon normal, dass man halt so einen Prompt hat und Code irgendwie sofort ausführen kann. Dass diese ganzen Kompilations-Stages, wenn es sie überhaupt noch gibt, quasi verschwinden oder so schnell im Hintergrund ablaufen, dass du davon eben nichts merkst. Und zunehmend, dass ja eben auch dieses Beispiel getriebene, ich lerne Stück für Stück, aber ich hab nie links meinen Computer, wo ich mich mit einem Setup rumschlage und dann hab ich die Dokumentation daneben liegen, sondern dass das quasi alles eins ist. Mehr wollte ich da eigentlich gar nicht zu sagen. Aber es gibt halt einen Begriff dafür und das ist halt Literate Programming. Und alle Projekte, die ich bisher gesehen habe, die diesen Geist aufgegriffen haben, das ist immer so, ja genau so will man das eigentlich haben. Warum ist Dokumentation eigentlich immer so schwierig zu konsumieren? Das stimmt schon. Hat auch den großen Vorteil, dass diese Dinger in der Regel viel fehlerfreier sind. Also früher konnte man ja seinen eigenen Progress beim Programmieren daran festmachen, wie viele Fehler man in dem Buch gefunden hat. Also ging es mir irgendwie nach dem Motto, jetzt bin ich mir bei 10 Bugs total sicher, dass es da falsch ist. Jetzt habe ich es wohl langsam verstanden. Und im Idealfall hast du das natürlich in so einem Environment gar nicht mehr, weil das so durchgetestet ist, dass da eigentlich gar nichts schiefgehen kann. Zumindest die Beispiele nicht.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall gibt es schon auch gute Doku, aber es gibt auch schon viel schlechter. Das stimmt.
Oder komplett fehlende. Zum Thema Google, das ist aber bei Google scheinbar ganz normal, dass man Doku bei Google immer googeln muss. Also, das scheint nicht in deren... Nein, es ist wirklich so. Es scheint nicht in deren DNA zu sein, dass man Doku schreibt, sondern man muss immer die Suchmaschine danach fragen, was man wissen will. Und wenn man die ersten 20 Hits gelesen hat, dann kann man sich halbwegs sicher sein, dass man schon das Richtige tut. Also das ist irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht wieso, aber das ist bei denen einfach so.
Dann googelt man halt Google. Wie hieß es bei IT-Crowd so schön? Oder war es IT-Crowd? Du type Google, into Google, then was passiert dann? Wo kommt denn das her?
Ich erinnere mich.
Ist doch IT-Crowd oder nicht?
Ich würde auch meinen. Es ist schon so lange her, dass ich IT-Crowd gesehen habe. Ich glaube, ich könnte es nur wieder sehen.
Weil du hier gerade noch in der Swagger-Doku da oder der Seite rum brauchst. Es gibt auch noch ein paar andere Tools, die quasi gestatten von so Jason Schema, auch so RP-Dokumentation zu generieren.
Never type Google into Google.
Was alles so komplett macht. Aber es gibt auch noch leichtgewichtigere, die nur so Jason-ARPs machen.
If you type Google into Google, you can break the Internet.
Ihr seid gewarnt, Leute.
Die haben noch keinen Humor, weißte doch.
Und die Leute, die uns jetzt zuhören, die IT-Crowd nicht kennen.
Das kennt sogar die Letty, das muss man gesehen haben.
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ihr seid zu jung.
Und ich weiß auch, warum ich's nicht gesehen hab, wie ich gerade gesehen hab. Englischer Humor, so das geht einfach nicht. Was? Dieses reingeklatsche...
Also das war doch ein bisschen zu viel eingespieltes Lachen.
Ja, ich hasse das. Ich kann selber denken. Wirklich.
Dennis, das musst du wirklich geguckt haben.
Das ist wirklich großartig.
Das hat er nicht gerade gesagt, oder? Du, der alle Filme der Welt gesehen hat. Du hast IT-Crowd nicht gesehen? Aber das ist doch der beste, solideste, nachhaltigste und lustigste Kommentar zum Thema Nerds ever.
Es mag sein, dass es an der Präsentation liegt, aber ich könnte es nicht verkraften. Keine zehn Minuten. Das ging jetzt schon nicht. Ich kenne überhaupt nichts Lustigeres.
Du bist jetzt aber nach dem heutigen Beispiel echt nicht mehr der Marsch.
Dann mal los, ich spiele gleich deinen Musikvorschlag.
Das war kein Vorschlag, das war ein Vorschlag von dem Giftschrank.
Nein, bitte nicht noch mehr von diesen Schlagern heute.
Ich habe ein bisschen Probleme mit fremdschamtriggernden Dingen und da gehört das sicherlich ganz...
Ich habe ja schon den mangelnden Humor beklagt. Ich sage es euch mal nebenbei, hier wurde Alexander Markus verlacht.
Wahrscheinlich kennt der Chat auch nicht.
Das ist nicht der Typ aus der Marte.
Google nicht in Google eintippen, das ist nicht witzig.
Das war eine... Ich wollte es gerade sagen, da taucht es schon im Chat. Weißt du, was das ist? Dieses Bild, weißt du, was das ist? This, Dennis, is the Internet.
Das ist auch von der gleichen Sendung mit dem roten Button, the red button. Habe ich schon mal gehört, habe ich auch geguckt. Sorry Jungs.
Du musst es von Anfang an sehen.
Wirkt nicht bei mir, ich bin da immun. Ich kann mir das Life of Brian zehnmal hintereinander gucken und ich lache zehnmal immer wieder an den gleichen Stellen, weil es einfach geil. Das da ist nicht geil.
Dennis, wir werden das zusammen gucken.
Sorry, das geht nicht durch hier.
Doch, doch, das geht voll durch.
Nein, das scheitert.
Ja, ich auch.
Da erreicht ihr einfach keine Metaebene Compliance.
Sorry, du bist raus.
Ja, das Ding für mich ist, ich mag so diese Serien, also im Prinzip, ich kenne halt die echten Hacker und Nerds. Und das empfinde ich halt eher so als Verballhornung und fast schon, weiß nicht, ich finde das nicht gut.
Hast du IT-Crowd gesehen?
Nur Ausschnitte.
Ausschnitte?
Mach mich nicht fertig.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nur im Geland von Zwerg, weil danach verstehst du erst viel.
Du sag mal was!
Tu mal was! Stimme der Jugend, erhebe dich!
Also, Stephanie, soll einfach dieses Geklatsche da ausschalten.
Ich glaube, das ignoriert man irgendwann. Also, ich kann mich an das Geklatsche nicht erinnern.
Ja, weil dein Gehirn ist mutsch geworden, deswegen. Meinst du nicht?
Papaya, Papaya, Havaitus, das volle Programm. Das sind Leute, die mich verstehen. Meine Hörer.
Die sind auf deinem Niveau, ja.
Aber du bist auch schon bei Meta-Humor angelangt. Du findest das nur geil, weil andere das so doll nicht geil finden.
Ach, die Freak Show in zwei Wochen, nur mit Tim.
Humor befreite.
Lad doch einfach diesen, wie heißt der? Alexander Markus ein.
Ja, und Fire auf die Papaya.
Irgendwas mit A-Pi war gerade.
Lettie ist fertig mit ihrem Rand.
Großer Herzschmerz. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Tisch.
Wenn ich dieses das sehe.
Das ist so wie diese Leute.
Das wart ihr doch auch.
Wer von euch war das? Irgendjemand fand hier L'Oréal nicht mehr lustig.
Ich kann damit nichts sagen.
Weißt du, wie alt ich mich fühle? Das geht aber auch nicht. Man kann Deutschland nicht verstehen, wenn man L'Oréal nicht verstanden hat.
So läuft es jetzt auch nicht.
Diese Einschränkung macht mich fertig.
Behauptest du das jetzt auch von Heinz Rühmann?
Ich gehe gleich, nein. Natürlich nicht.
Heinz Erhard meinste.
Ich würde das für Helge Schneider sagen.
Heinz Erhard ist Grenzfall.
Heinz Erhard ist grenzwertig. Auf eine ganz bestimmte Art und Weise.
Das wird mir ein Gesicht.
So ein Dicker mit so einem runden Gesicht.
Ich hab in der Schule, als wir uns mal ein Gedicht frei aussuchen durften, zum Vortragen, da hab ich eins von Heinz Erhard genommen. Welches? Hinter eines Baumes Rinde. Hinter eines Baumes Rinde sitzt die Mahle mit dem Kind.
Sehr lange herrlich, ich kann nur noch den Anfang.
Ihnen wird zur Last gelegt, sie hätten an ihm ausgesiegt.
Das ist Otto Walke, jetzt kommt mir nicht damit.
Wir schmeißen einfach mal alles durcheinander.
Die Mahle, da oben haben wir es doch.
Was ist das?
Ist das hier das Original?
Könnte sein.
Muss schon seine eigene Stimme sein.
Nein, das ist es nicht.
Da, da war es gerade.
Geh nochmal zurück.
Geh nochmal zurück in das Video. Da war eine Suggestion für das nächste Video. Und da war es gut. Nee, da wo du gerade warst.
Dieses Video, klick das nochmal an.
Und dann da.
Zerschmetzt.
Das ist ja doch auch nicht, oder?
Nein, das ist doch nicht.
Der sieht nur so aus. Da siehst du ja, wie der aussieht.
Das ist kein Original von... Das kann doch wohl nicht sein.
Wir prangern das an.
Heinz Erhard ist ein absoluter Gedichtskünstler. Und das mit der Made, das kann doch jetzt nicht sein.
Das ist davon. Ich hatte es auch noch aus dem Buch, natürlich.
Hat es nie gegeben und war gar nicht von Heinz Erhard.
Ah, der G-Sketch. Oh Gott, da weiß ich aber nicht mehr, wie lustig der war.
Ich will jetzt aber auch die Made.
Ja, wobei das nicht das Beste ist mit der Made.
Ist egal, aber darum geht es jetzt.
Er ist halt ein Wort, er hat den Wort König Erl.
Vielleicht heißt das gar nicht die Made.
Nein, das heißt die Made.
Dann such du doch mal Hucke und wir machen ein bisschen Sendung.
Naja, wenn es da auf YouTube nicht ist, dann könnte man auf iTunes, vielleicht in iTunes Music, ein Audiodokument finden.
Beliebte Videos vielleicht, das ist ja dabei.
Ich such mal ein iTunes. Vielleicht finden es ja auch Hörer im Chat.
Ist das vielleicht von ihm?
Zu viel Musik.
Vielleicht kommt da noch ein Spieler.
Egal, wir verschieben das.
Der Chat hat mal die Aufgabe, ein Original Die Made gesprochen von Heinz-Erhard zu suchen, während wir vielleicht so ein bisschen Sendung machen.
Erzähl doch mal was.
Nicht so aus dem Steg, ich bin gar nicht dran vielleicht.
Doch, doch, du stehst nach mir.
Das Konzept gibt es bei uns doch sowieso nicht.
Wir gucken mal, ob hier irgendwo noch mal...
Ich hab keinen Bock zu erzählen, weil ich tausendmal unterbrochen bin, weil dann plötzlich die Made gefunden wurde. Hat da einer gefunden?
Was? Nein.
Die Made von Heinz-Erhard.
Schick da mal drauf. Einen Versuch haben wir noch.
War das nicht das, was ich vorhin schon...
Nee, hat sie einen Baum. 200.000 Aufruf könnte passen.
Hinter eines Baumes Rinde wohnt die Made mit dem Kind. Sie ist Witwe, denn der Gatte, den sie hatte, fiel vom Blatte. Diente so auf diese Weise einer Ameise als Speise. Eines Morgens sprach die Made. Liebes Kind, ich sehe gerade, drüben gibt es frischen Kohl, den ich hole, so lebt den Wohl. Halt noch eins, denk was geschah, geh nicht aus, denk an Papa. Also sprach sie und entwich. Made Junior, aber schlich hinterdrein, und das war schlecht, denn schon kam ein bunter Specht und verschlang die kleine Fahde Made ohne Gnade. Schade. Da kommt doch noch was. Ich sag schon, wenn. Hinter eines Baumes Rinde ruft die Made nach dem Kinde.
War das, also...
Das war Heinz Erhardt himself.
War das so Stand-up-Gedicht? Also hat er sich das gerade außen gezogen?
Ich muss da mal was ganz Allgemeines sagen.
Jetzt sag mal was Allgemeines.
Und ich verstehe ja auch, warum das schwierig ist. Aber es ist trotzdem sinnvoll, den Aufwand, der erforderlich ist, zu leisten. Ich sage das jetzt. Also Humor ist immer kontextsensitiv. Und zwar sowohl kontextsensitiv in der jeweiligen Situation, als auch kontextsensitiv in der aktuellen kulturellen Realität. Das heißt, man kann jetzt nicht Heinz Erhard oder Otto Walkes nehmen, abspielen und dann so, was ist denn daran lustig? Weil das funktioniert natürlich in unserem Kontext nicht so.
Man muss schon den Kontext, den der Witz, zur Zeit des Witzes und das Drumrum und die Politik und alles, was sich so bezieht, muss man schon kennen. Das ist genauso wie Huckel sagt, Blade Runner, 80er Scheiße. Weil Huckel die 80er nicht kennt. Ich gehe das schon ein, aber ich kann jetzt halt mit IT-Crowd, in welcher Zeit geht das? Wie alt ist der Kram?
Lass mal erst mal IT-Crowd außen vor. Obwohl ich glaube, dass du da komplett falsch liegst. Aber Heinz Erhard ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel. L'Oreal ist auch ein sehr gutes Beispiel. Wenn jetzt Leute sagen, L'Oreal kann ich nicht witzig finden, dann weiß ich schon, woher das kommen könnte. Naja, das ist ja kein Vorwurf. Man kann sich ja nicht älter machen als man ist. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die durchaus zu so einem Zeitpunkt gelebt haben und trotzdem die kulturelle Realität um sich herum nicht verstanden haben. Und dann halt auch nichts verstehen. Weil Humor auch eine gewisse Intelligenz voraussetzt. Humor ist was für intelligente Leute.
Der Tim hat gerade gesagt, ich bin doof.
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil. Du bist hoch intelligent. Du verstehst ja auch den Humor unserer Zeit. Du hast dich nur offensichtlich mit irgendeinem Aspekt der Zeit von L'Oreal so noch nicht auseinandergesetzt. Was mich nicht überrascht, weil auch ich habe mich ja zu irgendwelchen Zeitpunkten noch nicht unbedingt mit dem, was 20 Jahre vor mir war, wo ich ja auch überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit hatte, das jetzt nennenswert in mich aufzusaugen, weil ich auch genug damit zu tun hatte, erstmal die aktuelle Zeit in mich aufzusaugen. Man ist ja erstmal immer gerade in seinen 20ern damit beschäftigt, erstmal die aktuelle Zeit aufzusaugen. Dann hat man vielleicht mal ein bisschen Ruhe und dann blickt man weiter zurück. Bei mir war L'Oreal, der lief halt noch im Fernsehen, als ich irgendwie schon junger Hüpfer war. Und da war das halt einfach unfassbar komisch, weil er eben wie kein anderer diese Gesellschaft in seinen Sketchen einfach reflektiert hat. Das war Deutschland, diese ganze Steifheit, dieses ganze verlorene Getue, dieses ganze Etepithete, dieser Sexismus, alles, was er da permanent passiviert. Das war einfach die knallharte Realität. Genau so war es. Und auch jemand wie Heinz Erhard, da denkt man sich, was ist das für ein Haini, der Sprachwitzgedichte auf der Bühne macht und alle kichern halt so.
In der Nachkriegszeit, das muss man dazu sagen.
Genau, das war ein irgendwie subversiv, vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen hohes Wort, soweit würde ich ihn jetzt nicht anhören, aber er hat auch seine Art und Weise eine Kritik ist zu formulieren, eben über so einen wunderbaren Sprachwitz, der eben in seiner ganzen Präsentationsform für alle sehr zugänglich war. Er war akzeptiert. Heinz Erhard konnte sich eben alles rausnehmen und hat dann eben auch lustige Sachen. Wenn man sich mal durchbingt bei Heinz Erhard, dann kommt man irgendwann auch auf den Film. Der Typ war einfach extrem lustig und extrem humorvoll. Nur ich finde halt nichts toppt L'Oréal. L'Oréal ist einfach die Krönung des deutschen Humors gewesen. Und seitdem ist halt relativ wenig passiert.
Also ich sehe... Seitdem ist relativ wenig passiert, das würde ich auch unterschreiben.
Wenig, ja. Also wenig, was in diese gerade Bereiche hinein ragt. Ich hätte jetzt ein paar Vorschläge, mit denen werdet ihr wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht einverstanden.
Wie sieht es denn aus mit dem Scheibenwischer?
Trau dich.
Wer ist denn der Scheibenwischer?
Scheibenwischer Dietmar Hildebrandt.
Ja, also die Kabarett...
Also mehr politisch halt.
Ja, die Kabarett-Fraktion ist da auf jeden Fall zu nennen. Mir würde dann eher Gerhard Pold einfallen.
Ja, Gerhard Pold ist schon heftig.
Gerhard Pold ist auch extrem gut.
Ja, der ist immer ein bisschen schmerzhaft, finde ich. Also das muss man sonst nicht darauf einlassen, weil der ist echt, gerade so Sachen wie Mai Ling, wo er davon erzählt, dass er sich die Thailänderin geholt hat, also das ist schon Hammerhart.
Ja, er ist knallhart, aber er berührt die Wahrheit. Also er durchschneidet die Wahrheit. Gerhard Pold hab ich mal live gesehen, ich hab mich in dem Abend überhaupt nicht mehr eingekriegt. Das ist wirklich fantastisch, auch seine Filme, alles großartig. Dieses Mann spricht Deutsch und so. Dieses ganze Deutsch-Tum ist bei ihm auch extrem gestrandet. Gerhard Pold würde ich wirklich noch vor... Hilde Brandt war Schneidiger, politischer Begleiter und er hat es so rein auf einer rein politischen Ebene...
Das ist man auch glücklich zu der Zeit gesehen. Ich glaube nachträglich bringt das gar nicht mehr so viel, weil man weiß die politischen Kontexte halt nicht mehr. Was ich letztens noch mal geguckt hab, was immer noch, weiß nicht wie viel, 40 Jahre später geht, ist Ekel Alfred. Das geht immer noch, das geht schon wieder sozusagen.
Ein Herz und eine Seele. Fantastisch, aber das war natürlich halt diese eine schauspielerische Performance sozusagen. Das war ja nicht so...
War so eine Serie aber.
Ja gut, aber es war ja, kann man, finde ich, ein bisschen schwer vergleichen. Ich rede halt jetzt so...
Aber Dieter Krebs war ja schon auch auf jeden Fall, den fand ich zum Beispiel auch früher ganz geil.
Dieter Krebs war durchaus lustig, aber weißt du, wenn ich jetzt noch gebracht hätte, dass du im Chat kamst, auch schon Helge Schneider?
Ja, das ist für mich der absolute...
Helge Schneider finde ich...
Der Mann ist als Pferd Scheiße.
Also, als du vorhin meintest, man kann Deutschland irgendwie verstehen oder... Also ich würde auch sagen, wenn irgendjemand nicht aus Deutschland über Helge Schneider, also wenn man den verstanden hat... Versteht keiner. Genau, es versteht keiner. Aber wenn, dann hast du den Integrationstest auf jeden Fall zu 100% bestanden.
Oh ja, genau. Ich meine, auch L'Oreal kann es halt nicht außerhalb von Deutschland niemanden erklären.
Wobei, so sei es, das Bild hängt schief oder so, wo ja auch gar nicht viel geredet wird, das ist ja so ein bisschen so, ich sage jetzt mal Slapstick, aber...
Ja, aber da steckt halt viel drin. Gerade, das ist ja überhaupt, ich finde, das ist einer der besten Sketche, wenn nicht überhaupt der beste Sketch, den L'Oreal je abgeliefert hat, weil diese ganze Verzweiflung des Individuums, die sich da widerspiegelt, gefangen in seinen Bewegungsverhaltenszwängen, dass er noch nicht mal in der Lage ist, in so einem Wartezimmer mit sich selber rauszukommen, dabei irgendwie das komplette Inventar...
Hast du eigentlich so dieses Milieu oder Gesellschaft, die man in L'Oreal je abgeliefert hat, wo alles perfekt sein muss und das Bild muss gras sein, hast du so eine Verwandtschaft, die so ist?
Die ganzen 70er waren so.
Ob du Verwandtschaft hast, die so ist?
Ich hatte Verwandtschaft in den 70ern.
Auch so, wo man die besucht hat und die genau so waren?
Na ja, es war natürlich immer etwas überzeichnet, aber die ganze Gesellschaft hatte einfach einen Stock im Arsch.
Du hast in Berlin geboren.
Berlin, klar, es gibt immer Nischen, da ist es irgendwie anders, aber man kann sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen, also die 70er waren ja schon geradezu revolutionär. Ich würde sagen, das, was L'Oreal da auch noch...
Das sind noch die 60er.
Das sind noch eher die Ausläufer der 60er. Also vor allem sind es ja immer so die älteren Leute, die die Gesellschaft prägen. Haben wir ja jetzt auch noch die 50-, 60-Jährigen, die die ganze Zeit die falschen Parteien wählen und uns irgendwie nerven.
Die dominieren ja immer noch so diesen Kultur...
Ja, ich gehöre schon dazu!
Und wie heißt ja noch der andere hier, den ich auch für unterschätzt halte, weil alle ihn immer nur für das Brandenburglied kennen.
Rebe, Reinhold Grebe.
Aber wenn man sich dadurch so in sein Repertoire mal durchhört, da sind schon auch ganz schön grandiose Gesellschaftsspiegel dabei. Da gibt es auch so eine Show, wo er vor diesem fälzischen SPD-Codeback oder so sitzt und so ein Lied schmettert und ihm auch immer so treue Blicke zuwirft, während er ihn durch den Kakao zieht. Der ist schon auch ein ganz guter. Aber Helge ist auf jeden Fall von dem gesamten Leistungsspektrum, der ja auch schon Dekaten quasi unterwegs ist.
Das Interessante ist, dass Leute, wenn du halt sich mit so Normalus unterhältst und den halt irgendwie Helge Schneider vorhältst, dann sagen die halt, der ist ja doof.
Oder beziehungsweise...
Weil er blödl, Bade, das wäre eher die Bezeichnung für...
Aber manchmal kann ich so den Background seiner Witze auch nicht so ganz verstehen, außer dass es an sich witzig ist, aber...
Naja, es gibt so ein Interview mit dem...
Schwierig zu erklären, warum das jetzt nicht total blöd ist.
Es gibt ein Interview mit dem, und zwar, ich glaube, das ist das einzige ernste Interview mit ihm. Da hat Christoph Schlingensief ihn in seiner Scheune oder so interviewt. Und die beiden haben irgendwie so ein Draht gefunden, wo Helge auch mal Fragen so straight beantwortet hat. Also so, wo du das Gefühl hattest, die unterhalten sich jetzt wirklich. Weil wenn du sonst immer interviewst mit Helge Schneider, du weißt, der hat eigentlich keinen Bock, der schmiert sich da seine Butterstulle in der Hotel-Lobby und beantwortet halt irgendwelche Fragen. Aber da dieses Interview mit dem Schlingensief, das war so, da hatte man das Gefühl, okay, der ist jetzt wirklich...
Jetzt ist mal wirklich Helge Schneider und nicht Doc Schneider.
Genau, und das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter genau. Da gibt es irgendwie zwei oder drei Teile sogar. Und das Ding ist ja, dass er selber gar nicht unbedingt lustig sein will, was ich als Komiker sieht, sondern gerade dann, wenn die Leute so am liebsten jetzt nur noch Katzenklo, da heute gibt es Reis hören wollen, dann macht er genau das Gegenteil als nächstes, also um die wieder alle runterzuholen, weil er auch gar keinen Bock hat bei seinen Shows, dass alle nur auf so diese vermeintlichen Hits so abgehen. Und das war ja auch mit den Filmen. Da hatte er einen Film, der war dann gerade so in den Medien und Show irgendwie gerade ganz gut unterwegs mit irgendeinem Quatsch. Und sein nächster Kinofilm war dann halt ein Film, wo er nur Jazz gespielt hat irgendwie und fast gar keine Dialoge und so weiter. Also dieses Perücke-Aufsetzen und Katzenklosing, das ist halt auch nur so eine Facette davon und gar nicht mal unbedingt jetzt so sein...
Ja, das ist der totale Ausriss. Er ist vor allem einfach ein großartiger Musiker und seine ganze Band und wie er alles auch so ad hoc macht. Alles ist ungeplant, also im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie hier.
Wie sind der hell geschnallte Podcast-Szene? Na ja, vielleicht ein bisschen weit gegriffen.
Ja, will mich da jetzt gar nicht vergleichen, aber er hat natürlich einen Stil, den ich sehr mag, weil er eben jenseits der Konvention geht. Ich erinnere mich noch an so einen Besuch, da war er mal bei, da ist ja noch gleich der Gummibärchenpaps, Thomas Gottschalk. Ja, mein Respekt gegenüber Thomas Gottschalk ist eingeschränkt.
Hey, die Supernasen waren super Film.
Der hat über seine Karriere sehr, sehr stark abgebaut. Also ich erinnere mich an meine frühe Jugend, fast Kindheit. Da hat er im Bayerischen Rundfunk noch Radio gemacht. Und das war ziemlich gut. Kennst du auch noch Tetespiele?
Damit ist er bekannt geworden im Fernsehen. Er hat so eine Sendung gemacht, wo die Leute dann über Telefonpong gespielt haben. So mit Lautstärke und so. Das war eigentlich mega innovativ damals. Thomas Gottschalk, Tetespiele, das war sein Fernsehdurchbruch. Und jetzt ist hier ein Clip. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob das der ist. Und zwar war das seine Late Show.
Uschi Obermeier und die Uschi.
Marcel Reichrad und Helge Schneider. Das ist ja eine geile Kombination.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es das jetzt war. Ich erinnere mich nur daran, dass Thomas Gottschalk den Fehler gemacht hat, ihn zu fragen oder zu bemerken, dass Helge Schneider, das ist eine interessante Information, die nicht jedem klar ist. Helge Schneider würde ja gar keine Werbung machen. Sagt Thomas Gottschalk, der sich für nichts zu scheiden ist. Und man muss sich das jetzt mal klar machen. Helge Schneider hast du noch nie auf irgendeinem Werbeplakat gesehen, was nicht für seine eigene Tour oder seine eigenen Platten geworben hat.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, der macht keine hier geile Chips und Helge und HaHa und Katzenklo und Streu und so.
Das hätte er machen können.
Aber locker.
Hätte dann auch nie wieder was anderes machen müssen. Aber macht er nicht. Ich habe das nur damals live gesehen. Ich habe nie davon aufzeichnet. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob der Clip das ist und ob ich das auch richtig erinnere. Auf jeden Fall. Du machst Gottschalk halt so Werbung und Helge Schneider poltert nur so raus. Ich sag erst mal, wie meine Erinnerung ist. Danach können wir mal überprüfen, ob es da mit was zu tun hat. Helge halt so sofort heraus. Ey, mach keine Werbung. Werbung ist Scheiße!
Und man merkt so richtig, wie so Thomas Gottschalk komplett zusammenfährt oder so.
Ich für so einen kurzen Moment nicht weiß, was er jetzt als nächstes fragen soll.
So komplettes D-Railing. Und ohne dass sich jetzt Helge vielleicht groß drauf angelegt hat, der hat halt einfach seine Meinung gesagt. Das ist bei mir natürlich sehr sympathisch. Ich harmoniere mit Helge Schneider. Und es hat nicht lang gedauert mit Helge und mir. Ich musste nur einmal so sein Album hören.
Und du warst hingeflossen.
Ja, ich meine, er spielt da ein Lied. Und dann im Lied ruft ihn jemand, ruft ihn ein Fan an. Klingelingeling, also er spielt so ein Lied. Klingelingeling, fängt an zu spielen.
Klingeling, Telefon.
Ja, ja, ist jetzt grad nicht so gut. Ich nehm mir grad ein Lied auf. Und legt dann.
Ich weiß noch, wie glaube ich bei Fritz Radio ganz früher haben sie ihn halt rein geholt oder eingespielt und hat irgendwelche Sketche erzählt von, dass er erzählen wollte von seinem Urlaub und dann kommt er wieder nach Hause, war wieder in Deutschland, macht dann das Portemonnaie auf und dann ist da noch ein Haifisch drin, den er aus Versehen aus dem Urlaub mitgebracht und dann erzählt er halt irgendwie so. Ich kann mich nicht mehr so genau erinnern, aber das war doch, bevor man den sonst überhaupt irgendwie kannte, hat er da aber schon bei Fritz Radio seine Spots.
Und mein Geheimtipp für Helge Schneider-Freunde, die das vielleicht noch nicht, ich habe es bestimmt schon mal erwähnt, dieses Globus Day Hörbuch von ihm.
Haben wir das mal hier?
Haben wir schon mal erwähnt, ich höre das wirklich einmal pro Jahr rein. Mittlerweile kann ich es schon weitestgehend mitsprechen, aber das bereitet mir doch immer wieder große Freude, weil er dann eine Weltreise beschreibt, die er aber nie physisch angetreten ist, sondern nur beschreibt, wie er sich das so vorstellt, wie er eine Weltreise macht, aber das als Fakten präsentiert, und das ist ein ganz großes Kino. Also es macht auch wirklich so abends zum Einschlafen ein schönes Kopfkino, dieser Stimme zuzuhören, wie er dann vom Polarkreis erzählt und allem Möglichen.
Apropos Hörbuch, für mich sind Hörbücher eigentlich für immer versaut, weil ein Freund von mir hatte mal das Hörbuch von Dieter Bohlen. Und das ist auch von Dieter Bohlen gesprochen und es ist auch irgendwie unfreiwillig komisch. Es ist wirklich auch unfreiwillig komisch irgendwie, aber was der was der für einen Scheiß erzählt, also das hätte man bei dem Namen schon ahnen können. Ja, ich war mir das Ausmaß nicht bewusst.
Macht er eigentlich immer noch seine Sendung?
Keine Ahnung.
Deutschland sucht den Superstar oder was auch immer. Was ist das da? Macht er nicht am Jury oder so? Ist das nicht seine Sendung? Also ihr seht schon, wir gucken alle kein Fernsehen.
Wir sehen kein Fern.
Was als Hörbuchstimme mich ja komplett weggehauen hat, war, scheiße, jetzt komm ich nicht auf den Namen der Kleine Dicke.
Dirk Bach.
Den fand ich immer so als Bühnenperson nie so richtig interessant und habe aber von Walter Mörs die Hörbücher gehört, von Dirk Bach gelesen und ich war so bei den ersten Minuten so, oh nee, ey, nicht der und er hat das aber so grandios gut gelesen, es ist eine wahre Freude war irgendwie.
Ich glaube der Jürgen von der Lippe kann das auch.
Ja, den finde ich auch ziemlich cool von der Stimme her.
Der ist auch ganz schön lustig, der Dirk Bach. Der ist, war ein, ja leider ist er ja tot, ein kluger Typ und das ist ja.
Ich habe bei manchen, die werden auch so in Rollen reingedrängt, wo sie anscheinend dann auch nicht mehr so easy wieder rauskommt. Vielleicht hätte es dem Dirk Bach auch gut getan, wenn er nicht so hätte sich verblödeln lassen.
Also ich fand den halt von der Stimme her, was der so alles an Emotionen und Stimmenlagen auf dem Kasten hatte, da gerade hier die 13,5 Leben des Captain Blaubeer. Was habe ich gelacht? Ich glaube, der hat auch mein Studium ein bisschen drunter gelitten, weil ich immer Hörbuch gehört habe, wenn ich nicht mehr.
Ich weiß, wounter dein Studium gelitten hat.
Nicht an der WoW.
Es waren meist Bücher, die mir die Noten versaut haben. Nee, aber ich habe halt häufiger am Wochenende mal so schnell ein Buch durchgelesen, weil es irgendwie so super spannend war, statt für Datenbanken 2 zu lernen. Wie hieß das damals? Datenbankenprogrammierung.
Voll reingefallen.
So, wollen wir mal wieder zur Technik kommen im 21. Jahrhundert? Das steht irgendwie in unserem Untertitel, glaube ich. Ich würde mal sagen, Dennis leg mal los und erzählt uns mal was Neues gibt an der Geldfront.
An der Geldfront, weil ich habe ja letztens mit meinem Kumpel Warren gesprochen. Ich war, wann war das, vor so zehn, elf Tagen an dem Wochenende war ich auf so einem kleinen Bitcoin Lightning Meetup, wo sich so die Leute, die sich so mit Bitcoin Lightning Networks beschäftigen.
Was sind Bitcoin Lightning?
Na das kommt dann gleich. Langsam. Jedenfalls habe ich mich mal reingesetzt, weil ich habe es bisher immer gut geschafft, mich nicht reinzulesen, was Lightning Networks denn so sind und dachte mir jetzt irgendwann, jetzt geht es ja dann doch relativ schnell vorwärts da in dem Themenbereich. Ich muss da jetzt mal so den Deep Dive machen, bin dahin. Und da wurde auch gesagt, dass es gibt einen 3 Stunden Lightning Networks Deep Dive Talk, der sozusagen einmal irgendwie das komplett erklärt, dass man es irgendwie verstanden hat oder zumindest alles schon mal gehört hat, wenn man es dann demnächst mal noch ein bisschen mehr hört, damit man dann schon wieder so eine Ahnung hat. Weißte, man muss immer so ein bisschen aufbauen und so Sachen lernen. Man versteht man es nicht beim ersten Mal, aber dann halt beim nächsten Mal. Jedenfalls hat mir das mich gut vorwärtsgebracht. Ich weiß jetzt, was Lightning Networks sind und das will ich jetzt vermitteln, Herr Hucki. Und zwar, erst mal müssen wir das Problem irgendwie ein bisschen beschreiben. Wir wissen ja bei Bitcoin, wenn wir eine Überweisung machen, das landet alles in der Blockchain, die Blockchain, die wächst. Das muss alles verarbeitet werden. Die Blöcke, die in der Blockchain landen, sind ja von der Größe begrenzt. Selbst wenn das jetzt ein bisschen verbessert wurde, man kann das auch optimieren und hier und da, aber am Ende landet alles in der Blockchain, obwohl du wieder mal nur deinen Kaffee gekauft hast. Und das ist halt ein bisschen expensive für so eine Technologie wie Blockchain, dass da jeder Scheiß drin landet. Das will man ein bisschen auslagern.
Jetzt auch mit Kinderpornos, ne?
Jedenfalls um das Problem zu umgehen mit den tausenden Transaktionen, die gar nicht unbedingt in die Blockchain rein müssen oder dass man das verhindert, dass die da reinkommen, gibt es halt Lightning Networks. So, und das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass, sag ich mal, Timme hat irgendwie einen Coffee-Shop und ich bin irgendwie Famous-Customer, der jeden Tag morgens irgendwie verarbeitet, sich da seinen Koffie holt und ich will immer mit Bitcoin bezahlen. Dann wäre jetzt im alten Fall gewesen, dass ich immer jeden Morgen komme, mit meinen Bitcoins bezahle, der Monat ist rum und wir haben dann 30 Transactions in der Blockchain drin, weil ich jeden Tag einmal meinen Kaffee bezahlt habe. Das heißt, pro Monat wären das 30 Transaktionen. Das will man ja verhindern. So und das Lightning Network denkt sich jetzt, wenn wir beide ja einen Monat lang jeden Tag eine Transaction machen, dann könnte man das ja eigentlich zusammenfassen, wenn man das jetzt mal auf diesen Monat betrachtet als Beispiel, dass ich ja am Anfang des Monats komme, wir spulen den Monat vorwärts und am Ende des Monats gebe ich dir 30 mal hier so ein Milli-Bitcoin oder was auch immer so ein Kaffee irgendwie kostet, so die Gesamtsumme und dann wäre das ja eine größere Transaction. Das wäre ja eigentlich so das Optimale, wenn man das auf eine zusammenschrumpfen kann. So geht es natürlich auch nicht, aber bei den Lightning Networks macht man das so, dass wir am Anfang des Monats so eine Art Channel eröffnen. Das heißt, ich mache eine Überweisung, die, ich nehme einfach mal so ein zehntel Bitcoin, also eine geringe Summe, die meinen Kaffeebedarf für einen Monat abdeckt und pack die so in eine Transaction, dass man 2 of 2 Multisignature braucht, um die wiederzubekommen. Das heißt, ich kann die alleine nicht mehr ausgeben, du alleine aber auch nicht, aber wir beide zusammen.
Moment, stopp, irgendwie bist du jetzt schon viel zu weit nach vorne geradet.
Du hast drei Sprung, ihr dürft jetzt nachfragen.
Ja, also ich komme mal von der anderen Seite.
Also ich hatte bisher immer folgende Eindruck, vielleicht liege ich ja komplett falsch. Diese Lightning Networks sind quasi eine der Blockchain zusätzlich beigelegte Datensstruktur, die aber für sich erstmal separat ist.
Die hat mit der Blockchain erstmal nichts zu tun. Die haben jetzt gerade an dem Bitcoin zwar schon mit dem Seqbit was geändert, was das Lightning Network braucht, aber das Bitcoin braucht eigentlich nichts von dem Lightning. Also das hat miteinander nichts zu tun, sondern das Lightning Network.
Eine zweite Datensstruktur, die aber selber keine Blockchain ist.
Korrekt. Das, was wir da machen und regeln und aufbauen benötigt, macht schon auch eine Transaktion.
Was heißt, was wir da machen?
Machst du da jetzt auch schon mit, bist du da jetzt?
Wir beide. Gut, also nochmal. Blockchain funktioniert nicht, weil zu viele Transaktionen, die passen da nicht mehr rein. Die Blöcke sind voll, die Transaktionen sind teuer, alles schwierig, dauert.
Teuer sind die gerade nicht, die Blöcke sind da gerade nicht voll, aber man will ja für den nächsten Strom, der kommt, man will ja optimieren. Und da sind natürlich schlaue Jungs, die da dran weiterarbeiten. Und eine Lösung ist halt Lightning Networks.
Sind das eigentlich nur Jungs?
Bei der Veranstaltung, nee, da war auch Mädel, die sich auch ziemlich gut mit Lightning Networks auskannte, aber ist wie mit allen Sachen erstmal, ich würde mal sagen, zehn Prozent Frauen. Und da war es sogar eher weniger, würde ich sagen, aber ja.
So und Lightning Networks sind jetzt eine andere Struktur. Wie, was für eine Struktur, also was für eine Art Datenstruktur wird da aufgebaut? Ist das auch so eine Distributed Database, die nur anders funktioniert?
Ja, das ist alles Crypto abgesichert, weil sonst geht es ja nicht. Weil du kannst mir nicht trauen, ich kann dir nicht trauen. Ist halt so, Händler, also Client-Customer Relationships. Deswegen, wenn ich mit dir ein Channel aufmache, packe ich so viel rein, dass sagen wir mal für einen Monat mein Kaffeekaufkraft gedeckt wäre. Also damit ich einen Monat damit weit komme, damit wir nach einem Monat den Channel wieder zumachen können. Irgendwann muss man ihn ja wieder schließen.
Also das ist das, was ein Lightning Network macht. Es erstellt Channels zwischen zwei Zahlungspartnern.
In unserem Fall, weil man kann es nachher dann so ein bisschen ausbauen, aber zwischen uns ist es jetzt erstmal ein Channel zwischen mir und zwischen dir. Und die Bezahlungen gehen von mir zu dir, wobei man das auch wieder in die andere Richtung machen könnte.
Und vor allem ist er zeitlich begrenzt. Also man sollte ihn zeitlich begrenzen?
Nee, eigentlich ist er nicht wirklich begrenzt. Das ist jetzt mal nur so zur Annahme. Was die harten Zahlen sind, die kann man glaube ich schon alle dynamisch festlegen. Ich komme ja noch gar nicht so richtig zum Erzählen hier. Da kommen noch so ein paar Sachen. Ich lasse mir erstmal das Gesamtkonzept so ein bisschen mehr ausrollen und dann können wir noch so ein bisschen die Feinheiten nachtunen und nacherklären.
Ja, ich versuche auch nur bei dem Gesamtkonzept zu bleiben, aber was ist das Ziel dieser ganzen Geschichte? Warum? Was sollen Lightning Networks dem Bitcoin-Blockchainsystem hinzufügen? Was ist das?
Naja, wenn wir so einen Channel aufmachen, das wäre, ich überspringe jetzt ein paar Sachen, wir können gleich wieder tiefer rein gehen. Aber wenn wir so einen Lightning Network Channel eröffnen, dann ist das am Anfang eine Transaktion in die Blockchain. Dann würden wir einen Monat lang zwar was machen, aber nicht mehr in der Blockchain. Da würde erstmal nichts passieren, sondern es passiert sozusagen nur zwischen uns beiden. Das erkläre ich dann gleich. Und am Ende des Monats, wenn wir jetzt sagen, so reicht mir jetzt, ich gehe zu einem anderen Kaffee laden oder wie auch immer, oder ich will jetzt mal abschließen, dann schließt man den Channel wieder und das ist wieder eine Transaktion wieder in der Blockchain.
Verstehe, das ist wie so eine eigene Wurst, die man dann irgendwie mit beiden Zipfel in die Blockchain reinigt.
Wenn wir jetzt mal sagen, ein Kaffee kostet Millibitcoin und ich packe in den Channel mal 50 Millibitcoin rein, dann würde ich jeden Tag einen Millibitcoin in deine Richtung schieben. In der Blockchain würde man davon aber gar nicht sehen, sondern nur in unserer Channel würde die 50 Millibitcoin halt belegen. Das heißt, ich könnte dann auch nicht woanders benutzen, die sind sozusagen nur zwischen uns. Und nach einem Monat sagen wir, okay, ich habe jetzt 30 Kaffee bezahlt. Das heißt, wir schließen das jetzt so ab, dass tatsächlich 30 Millibitcoin davon bei dir landen, aber nur 20 bei mir wieder zurückkommen oder bei mir verbleiben.
Das heißt, jetzt verstehe ich es gerade. Das Lightning Network Hence the Name ist sozusagen eine schnelle Verbindung zwischen Zahlungspartnern, die unabhängig von der Blockchain-Registrierung abgeschlossen werden kann, damit sie diese ganze Trägheit dieser Blockchain gar nicht erst hat, sondern dass Zahlungswege sozusagen unmittelbar sind, schnell und auch keine Transaktionskosten oder wenig aufwerfen. Letztlich müssen sie aber natürlich auch in der Blockchain verankert werden, aber das sozusagen erst nach der Eröffnung ist eine Transaktion, ein Channel schließen ist eine Transaktion, das war's, mehr nicht.
Wir können dazwischen auch tausende machen, ich könnte jede fünf Minuten bei dir Kaffee kaufen.
Gut, aber wenn ich jetzt sozusagen, es hilft mir aber nicht, wenn ich jetzt mit vielen Partnern viele kleine Zahlungen habe, sondern nur wenn sozusagen zwei Partner haben?
Ja, also dieser Channel ist erst mal nur zwischen uns beiden. Ich würde aber erst eigentlich noch mal kurz bei dem Channel bleiben, bevor wir dann weitergehen, wie das mit mehreren Leuten ist, weil wir mussten kurz erklären, warum der Channel, warum man da nicht bescheißen kann.
Jetzt weiß ich aber zumindest schon mal, warum es das überhaupt gibt. Es geht sozusagen darum, wegzukommen von der Blockchain, von Transfektionskosten und Geschwindigkeit maximal.
Geschwindigkeit auch. Also das, was ich am Anfang erklärt habe, wenn ich den Kaffee normal bezahlt hätte, wären das 30 Transaktionen im Monat. Jetzt sind es halt nun noch zwei. Eine öffnendes Channel, eine schließendes Channel. Also anstatt 30 sind es zwei geworden. Oder anstatt 300 sind es zwei geworden. Oder anstatt wieviel auch immer sind es zwei geworden. Das Ding ist, damit du auf jeden Fall dein Geld kriegst und ich aber auch dafür sorgen kann, dass du mich nicht abzocken kannst, muss das ja auch ein bisschen abgesichert sein. Sonst stelle ich dir vor, ich habe dir... Ich komme jetzt jeden Tag und zahle dir einen Kaffee. Das heißt, jeden Tag geht ein Millibitcoin, sage ich jetzt mal, mehr zu dir rüber. Und dafür macht man immer so eine kleine neue Transaktion, die ich dir schon... Ich gebe dir was mit meiner Unterschrift, weil wir haben gesagt, man braucht Unterschriften von beiden Leuten, damit man an dieses Geld kommt. Und jeden Tag gebe ich dir sozusagen eine neue Unterschrift, dass dir jetzt 2 Millibitcoin gehört, am nächsten Tag gebe ich dir eine, dass dir jetzt 3 gehören. Du löst sie halt nur noch nicht ein, du behältst sie für dich. Und ich gebe dir jeden Tag eine neue, wenn ich mir meinen Kaffee hole, was auch ganz schnell geht, weil ich muss die ja nur geben, die muss nirgendswo gepusht werden. Und nach einer Woche hättest du dann schon 7 Millibitcoin und ich bin jetzt nur noch bei 43. So, jetzt ist aber die Sache, ich könnte jetzt ja die ganz erste nehmen, die ich unterschrieben habe, wo ich noch bei einem Kaffee war, wo du nur 1 Millibitcoin kriegst und ich 49, und könnte die in die Blockchain tun.
Und sozusagen nicht die ganzen anderen späteren Zahlungen überschrecken.
Genau, ich nehme die erste, die für mich am günstigsten ist, weil das muss ja gehen, weil auch ich muss ja dafür sorgen können, dass du mich nicht bescheißt, wenn du eines Tages weg bist. Das heißt, jeder muss eigentlich auch immer irgendwie an sein Geld rankommen. Und damit das nicht funktioniert, kann ich das zwar machen, aber das ist so geregelt, dass ich, wenn ich das mache, du dein Geld sofort kriegen würdest, und ich meine es erst eine Woche später. Das heißt, du hättest eine Woche Zeit, dass ich so eine alte Transaktion ins Bitcoin-Netzwerk geschoben habe und könntest dann darauf reagieren, mit einem weiteren Key, den ich dir vorher schon gegeben habe, damit du es dann doch dir holen kannst. Also das heißt, nutze den Zeitfaktor, damit du merkst, ich haue jetzt eine alte Transaktion raus, die ich eigentlich nicht mehr hätte raushauen sollen, damit du Zeit hast, dann eine neuere zu nehmen, weil wir haben ja eigentlich schon sieben Tage weiter. Du hast ja die neueste sozusagen. Das ist jetzt hier schwer zu erklären. Der Typ hatte da auch schon so ein bisschen Schwierigkeit mit, obwohl er Grafiken hatte. Wir mussten das zwei, drei Mal durchgehen. Aber es ist eigentlich sehr technisch, aber es ist auch sehr schlau gemacht. Es ist auf jeden Fall Zeitfaktor.
Also du könntest im Prinzip jederzeit von irgendeiner alten Transaktion sagen, das ist jetzt das alles, was abgelaufen ist, obwohl es mehr gab. Aber die andere Partei hat eine Woche Zeit, wo sie sich den Anspruch einzeln sagen, Caspar Kraft stimmt ja nicht, hier guckt mal.
Und auf diese Zeit stellen wir uns ein. Wir können auch sagen, wir wollen nur zwei Tage gucken, wir könnten aber auch vier Wochen sagen. Das ist aber auch so, wenn einer von beiden dann tot umfällt, dann muss der andere halt auch vier Wochen warten, bis er an seine Kohle rankommt, obwohl er nicht beschissen wurde, muss er dann so lange warten.
Aber dann würde man sich schon Geld sparen, wenn der andere tot umfällt.
Ja, da würden seine Erben ja dann auch diese theoretisch kriegen. Sie müssen halt nur die letzte Transaction, die sich die beiden geeinigt haben, raus schieben. Aber es ist sozusagen technisch geregelt, dass man nicht bescheißen kann. Und wenn der eine versucht, doch zu bescheißen, das geht schon, hat man aber vier Wochen Zeit, um das zu überstimmen mit einer neueren Transaktion, die man schon hat. Also weil ich mir mit jedem Tag was gebe, was das Alte sozusagen instantan überfällig macht. Irgendwie so.
Und wenn Tim die Möglichkeit hat, zu sagen, hier, nee, ist nicht, ist das dann so, also wenn du die eine ältere Transaktion reingeschoben hast, kann Tim dann automatisch sagen, nee, nee, nee, nee, das hier ist die neueste und dann würde die sozusagen sofort akzeptiert sein oder hast du dann auch noch mal die Möglichkeit irgendwie gegen zu checken, was Tim da reinspeist wieder?
Das ist so ein Hin und Her-Krieg, der durchgeht bis zur allerletzten Transaktion und die kann nicht mehr bestimmt werden, weil es gibt keine neuere mehr. So läuft das theoretisch. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwer zu erklären. Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass eine Seite immer, der, der bescheißt, bis der sein Geld kriegt, muss eine Woche warten und ich habe aber mit der nächsten neueren Transaktion ihm einen Key gegeben, dass er das sofort auslösen kann und eben nicht eine Woche warten muss, aber ich selber kann das nicht. Das ist, ja, kann man nicht so schwer erklären, aber es ist auf jeden Fall zeitbasiert.
Aber was hier gerade ein schöner Vergleich ist im Chat, Sascha, er meint ja, ja, ich heb ja auch 100 Euro vom Konto ab und zahle damit eine Woche lang meine Kleinigkeiten und überweise nicht den Bäcker 4,25 Euro. So könnte man das eigentlich durchaus sehen, dass so dieses Lightning-Netzwerk ist so quasi das rausgenommene Bargeld.
Nicht ganz, weil es Lightning-Network ist, weil es kommt ja gleich zum nächsten Punkt, wie du schon fragst, ob das dann nur zwischen uns beiden geht. Das Lightning-Network ist kryptomäßig schon auch abgesichert, also man kann nicht bescheißen, weil ich sehe das dann und kann dann immer nachgucken. Dazu muss man aber auch die Kanäle offen halten. Also ich muss sozusagen die eine Woche lang dann aktiv checken, ob du mich bescheißen wolltest oder nicht. Also ich muss sozusagen immer...
Ich sage nicht, es funktioniert genauso, aber das Bargeld als separater Zahlungskanal mit ganz anderen Bestätigungselementen als die Bankwege.
Der nächste ist schon besser. Ich hinterlege beim Bäcker 100 Euro. Also ich lasse nicht anschreiben, sondern ich hinterlege 100 Euro und kann solange Brötchen holen, bis der Bäcker sagt, du, deine 100 Euro sind jetzt weg. Nur, dass der Bäcker halt mit den 100 Euro abhauen kann und bei Lightning nicht, weil dann löse ich meine Transaction aus, die wir uns am Anfang ja gemacht haben beim Channel erstellen. Und du hast keine neuere von mir bekommen, um das zu übertrumpfen und dann kriege ich nach einer Woche mein Geld wieder.
Da könnte man ja im Prinzip auch so darstellen mit so einem Unterschriften, dass man so einen Tag hat, wo beide immer unterschreiben, dass so und so viel jetzt davon...
Das ist das, was bei Lightning einer...
Ja, so wie beim Hotel, wenn du da beim Frühstück bist und dann unterschreibst, dass du jetzt hier Frühstück geholt hast und so und danach zahlst du das alles mit deiner Rechnung.
Ja, so ein bisschen ist das so. So und jetzt kommt halt der Trick. Könnte man sagen, okay, dann ist Lightning ja nicht so spannend, weil ich gehe jetzt irgendwie in einem Restaurant, vielleicht dann nur einmal im Monat essen, was brauche ich da denn Lightning oder also mit dem brauche ich ja keinen Channel aufbauen und für einen Kaffee am Tag Channel lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht so wirklich. Wo ist das spannend? Das Ding ist, die haben das am Ende so hingekriegt, dass sich die Channels miteinander verknüpfen können. Das heißt, wenn ich zu dir Geld rüberschieben kann, wir beide haben aber gar keinen Channel, aber ich habe einen Channel zu Huckel und Huckel hat einen Channel zu dir, dann können wir das Krypto mich so hinkriegen, dass ich mein Geld zu Huckel schiebe und er schiebt es zu dir. Huckel hat keinen Nachteil, außer dass er eine kleine Gebühr dafür verlangen kann. Er kriegt sozusagen eine Fee fürs Durchreichen und ich hab ein bisschen weniger an meinen Bitcoins und du hast am Ende ein bisschen mehr und Huckel hat gleich viel, weil bei ihm wird es nur durchgeschoben und so kann man von einem Channel zum nächsten das so durchreichen und das alles kryptographisch total sicher. Und das ist das, was bei Bitcoin und bei den Lightning-Nodes gerade so abgeht. Es gibt schon mehrere tausende Lightning-Nodes und jeder kann es für jeden schieben und so. Das Schöne ist, dass es zwar eine Menge Traffic-Overhead ist und eine Menge Data-Overhead, aber das Geile ist, man kann alles wegschmeißen, wenn die Channels geschlossen werden. Das heißt, man muss nichts aufheben, außer Channel öffnen und Channel schließen im Bitcoin, sonst nichts. Und zur Zeit sind die noch sehr, sehr konservativ mit ihren Channels. Also da sind, also ich glaube, die maximale Summe, die in so einem Channel drin sein darf, hat er gesagt, wäre 0,15 Bitcoin oder so. Also sind wirklich von Volumen, also vom Money-Volume sind die sehr gering. Diese Lightning Channels. Aber da die alle miteinander verknüpft sind, kann man also Tor-Netzwerk mäßig von einem zum nächsten seine Kohle schieben. Auch anonym, die dazwischen wissen nicht, also wenn ich über Huckel zu dir Geld schiebe, dann weiß Huckel nicht, ob das von mir kam oder ob eigentlich Letty der Auftraggeber ist.
Und Letty ist über Dennis zu Huckel zu Tim geschrieben.
Genau, und ich weiß nicht, ob es von dir kam, weil das könnte auch sein, dass eigentlich du das nur von Roddy bekommen hast. Und dann, also weißt du, das ist so wie bei Tor, man weiß nicht, wo es herkommt. Man weiß nur von, wer kurz vor mir und wer kurz nach mir hat, aber den Rest würde man nicht wissen.
Du kennst die Zwiebelschale nur, die Roddy und Acht hier ist.
Genau, nur die connecten Partner, aber nicht die dahinter.
Und weil ich weiß, also wenn Roddy weiß, über diese ganzen Hops würde er irgendwie zu Tim kommen, funktioniert das deswegen, weil Roddy mich als Kontakt hat? Ich hab den Kontakt, also Roddy und ich tauschen das Secret auch?
Wie dieses Routingzeug, da weiß ich es nicht, aber das gibt es Routing-Protokolle und das handeln die da irgendwie aus, das ist keine Ahnung, das hab ich mich nicht mit, das ist im Netzwerk auch, Mesh-Network und Stuff, da...
Na, mich interessiert es wegen der Krypto. Also, wenn wir uns beide vertrauen, ist das eine Sache?
Geldmäßig war das kryptografisch geregelt, da kann keiner wegen Bescheißen unterwegs, das geht nicht, das haben die gefixt, wie das aber mit dem Privacy-Wissen ist und so, da hab ich, das kann ich nicht nacherzählen, das geht nicht.
Wie weit ist das jetzt umgesetzt?
Die benutzen das schon, es läuft schon, gibt's schon.
Die beiden gerade ihre Hände drin.
Die Developer benutzen das, oder?
Das Lightning Network, da das ja mit Bitcoin selber nichts zu tun hat, nicht direkt, ist es sozusagen nicht Teil des Bitcoin-Protokolls, das heißt, die müssen sich an gar keine Regeln halten, so richtig. Deswegen können die sich zusammensetzen, können sich was einfallen lassen, was funktioniert und das haben drei Firmen oder drei Implementationen gemacht. Haben gesagt, lasst mal gucken, wie wir interoperabel sein können und haben das so gemacht, bis es funktioniert hat und das ist irgendwie ja Blockstream, die man so ein bisschen kennt aus dem Bitcoin-Bereich und noch zwei andere Booten. Und die haben halt ja insgesamt drei Implementationen, zwischen einander halt Channels aufmachen können und das funktioniert schon, da sind die eine Menge am Machen und am Tun und am Experimentieren und Test.
Funktioniert das auch für was anderes außer Bitcoin?
Deren Zeug erstmal nicht, aber ich sehe da nicht so richtig die Behinderung, warum das auch nicht mit was anderem gehen soll.
Na gut, ich meine die ganzen Derivate da, Dogecoin, Bitcoin Cash.
Na mit denen geht sowieso, Litecoin hat das ja schon oder Honey Litecoin hat das ja schon. Weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich sehe keinen Grund, warum es da nicht gehen sollte. Also, ja.
Ok, aber das Lightning Network selber ist jetzt für Bitcoin? Du hast diesen Talk erwähnt, hast du den?
Da wurde nichts aufgezeichnet. Die sind noch nicht so Profimäßig.
Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen. Gerade so was Dokumentation betrifft, das Thema hatten wir ja schon.
Da wird schon, kann man schon noch sagen, viel mit der heißen Nadel gestreckt. Dafür strecken die aber auch ordentlich. Also ich meine, das ist jetzt noch so...
Aber soll ich dir sagen, wovon sie gar keine Ahnung haben? Buchhaltung. Das ist eine totale Katastrophe. Also wenn du jetzt wirklich mal seriös mit Bitcoin handeln willst und du willst mal halbwegs belastbare Dokumente vorlegen beim Finanzamt, dann ist das einfach so ein Dreck.
Ja, aber das ist nicht Teil der Blockchain. Das ist Teil von externen Tools, die das Standard-Protokoll benutzen. Dann musst du deine Tools da.
Ja, die Wallet, die Standard-Wallet irgendwie.
Es gibt eine Standard-Wallet, es gibt so viele andere Wallets.
Ja, aber schon das taugt halt nichts. Und der Rest ist da auch nicht so gut.
Das ist ein Programm, was weltweit läuft. Das hat mit deiner Buchhaltung hier, da können die noch nicht für kleinen Timmer aus Berlin ihre Kleinste anpassen.
Nee, die Anforderungen sind immer die gleichen, dass du einfach mal alles komplett nachvollziehen kannst. Punkt. Und das kannst du daraus nicht nachvollziehen. Das ist einfach vollkommen eine hanebüchener Miste, die da rausfällt.
Da beschwere ich bei denen nicht mal.
Hab ich schon.
Hab ich sehr ausführlich getan. Ich war erstmal ein bisschen schockiert. Weil die wollten mir die ganze Zeit irgendwas einreden, was ich mir jetzt irgendwie alles, was ich ja alles nicht richtig verstehen würde und behaupte. Und dann müsste man ja nochmal einen Podcast machen und so.
Und dann hast du dir erstmal herunter gebetet, was das A und O der Buchhalter ist?
Ja, ich hab mir das eine Weile angehört und dann hab ich irgendwann mal zu verstehen gegeben, dass ich die letzten Wochen vor diesem Gespräch mich irgendwie intensiv mit diesem ganzen Scheißdreck auseinandergesetzt habe. Gekotzt hab wie Weltmeister. Und hab dann mal so 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 10 Sachen irgendwie aufgezählt. Und da war dann schon so ein bisschen so, ah, oh, hm, ja, äh, hm, ja. Darüber haben wir noch nie nachgedacht. Das ist ein anderer Appeal, ne? Das ist sozusagen so ein Nerd, ich versteh das ja auch. Denen geht's da drum so, ne? Aber sie beklagen sich immer darum, dass sozusagen die Perzeption und die Adoption zu wünschen übrig lässt. Und dann sag ich so, ja, dann kümmert euch doch einfach mal um so ein paar Real-World-Interfaces. Dann könnte die Sache vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen funktionieren, ja? Es ist halt einfach eine Währung, die sozusagen sich als Zahlungsmittel dient. Aber nicht mal die Grundlagen von normalen Zahlungsmitteln erfüllt, indem man einfach mal nachvollziehen kann, was da eigentlich passiert. Du kannst nicht diese Wallet, die Markts, zwar ihre Crypto-Keys wunderbar vorhalten, aber einfach mal so eine einfache Frage wie unter welchen Adressen hast du denn hier alles gespeichert?
So, sag mal. Geht nicht.
Es ist einfach unmöglich. Und der CSV-Export, das ist so, oh Gott, ist ganz schlimm. Ganz schlimm ist das.
Es ist halt hier noch Pionierzeiten, immer noch.
Genau, nach neun Jahren.
Neun Jahre, ich meine. Okay, wir kennen das jetzt hier schon ein bisschen länger, aber ich meine, das ist ja auch eigentlich erst seit einem Jahr wirklich in den Mainstream News so gesehen, dass das ja für Normal-User top frischer Scheiß ist. Ist doch so, oder? Ich meine...
Wenn sich die Design-Studenten in der Tram darüber unterhalten, scheinbar schon.
Na gut, aber die geilen Talks, die alles erklären und dann aber noch nicht mal aufgezeichnet werden, ist schwierig. So, so viel zu Bitcoin.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall heißer Scheiß, fand ich. Und suddenly it all makes sense.
Ich muss mal hier in meiner Eigeninteresse gerade mal eine Frage an die Menschen da draußen, die vielleicht ein ähnliches Problem haben oder so, oder irgendwie so ein Tipp. Vielleicht fällt euch auch was ein. Ich hab so einen gebrauchten iMac, nicht der hier im Studio, zuhause. Und das Teil aktiviert seinen Monitor, wie nennt man das, rohe Zustand. Vermutlich, tippe mal auf...
Erstmal erklär mal, was der... Das dieser...
Der Monitor, Ruhe, Zustand, das was du auch über deine aktiven Ecken zum Beispiel, deine Hot Corners, auch explizit ansprechen kannst. Da gibt's genau diesen Ruhe-Zustand.
Und was heißt dein Ruhe-Zustand? Der Bildschirm geht aus, der Rechner läuft noch?
Der Bildschirm geht aus, der Rechner läuft noch.
Während du ihn benutzt.
Während du ihn benutzt. Der Rechner ist voll an. Aber der Bildschirm ist aus.
Und wie kriegst du ihn wieder an?
Indem du an der Maus wackelst. Du kannst in deinen Energy-Settings sagen, wann der Bildschirm ausgehen soll.
Wenn die Tore ausschalten, nach einer Stunde, steht jetzt bei mir.
Genau, und du kannst aber auch in deinen Active-Corner in die Maus, rechts unten, oder wo auch immer hin gehen.
Und bei dir geht er schneller aus als die Zeit?
Nein, er geht von alleine aus. Selbst wenn ich sage, gehe nie aus. Ich schalte den Rechner an, und nach 20 Minuten, deswegen glaube ich auch, dass das irgendwas mit Wärme zu tun hat, dass da irgendein Bauteil...
Da ist ein Lüfter hinten, weißt du das? Wo? Der iMac sieht ja aus wie so ein Cinema-Display, der hat ja diesen Scharnier hinten, wo der Halter dran ist, also dieser Alufuß. Und genau unter diesem Scharnier, hinter dem Aluhalter, da sind ja so ein paar Kühlritzen, richtig? Und bei meinem Cinema-Display, auch wenn man es fast nie hört, aber dahinter ist ein kleiner Lüfter und der geht sogar, selbst bei meinem Display, geht der manchmal an. Das heißt, mein Display hat einen kleinen Lüfter drin. Der geht selten an, aber im Sommer, bei voller Helligkeit, wenn das Ding warm wird, dann geht dieser kleiner Lüfter an und vielleicht geht der bei dir nicht mehr oder so.
Und du meinst, dass er sich Auto abschaltet? Weil er zu warm ist?
Vielleicht, weil er zu warm ist. Also deswegen ist es so eine Idee, immer Sachen, die man checken könnte.
Du könntest es mit Kältesprehen natürlich versuchen, nachzustellen, ob du, wenn du den ausreichend kühlst, er sich nach 20 Minuten nicht ausschaltet, dann hast du zumindest einen Hinweis darauf, dass es sich um ein Wärmeproblem handelt.
Kann ich da einfach Kältesprehe durch diesen Lüfterschlitz reißgeheusere?
Also meine Idee wäre, du betreibst den Monitor einfach mal mit einer deutlich geringeren Helligkeit, weil das ist das, was die Wärme erzeugt.
Moment, die Frage ist, wenn es an diesem Lüfter liegt, wie du sagst, dann dreht er sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht. Diese Lüfterdrehgeschwindigkeit kann man auch auslesen, über irgendwelche Tools.
Weiß nicht. Das ist ja nicht Teil vom SCM, sondern das ist ja dann das Display selbst, das ist wieder im USB angeschlossen. Im iMac ist das natürlich, aber bei mir ist das ja so. Im iMac weiß ich natürlich nicht, dann könnte der Lüfter, ja, installier doch mal.
I start menus. Lies dir den meisten Kram davon aus.
Okay, das ist ein guter Gedanke. Weil ich hab halt so den Effekt, der geht aus, so, und dann hab ich extra nochmal diese Active Corner eingeschaltet, damit ich quasi die Maus in diese Corner mache, wodurch er sich ja eigentlich erst ausschalten würde. Und wenn ich die Maus wieder rausnehme, also quasi explizit einschalte ich mal wieder ein, Trigger, dann schaltet er sich in dem Moment auch wieder an, aber nach einer Weile schaltet er sich halt immer wieder aus. Das heißt, der Rechner merkt gar nicht, dass, also es ist nicht die Software, die ihn ausschaltet, sondern vermutlich der Monitor, der sich selber ausschaltet, der sich aber wieder einschaltet, wenn der Rechner ihm sagt, schalte ich wieder ein. Ja, ist ja auch schräg, deswegen wollte ich das mal hier...
Und hast du auch mal so Power-Reset und SS-Tingram-Reset und all so Resets, die man so resetten kann?
Ja, guter Punkt, da könnte ich vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen resetten. Ich hab auch mal das OS neu installiert, das hat aber nix gebracht.
Also ich mein, wenn es ein Wärmeproblem wäre, dann durftest du den ja nicht gleich wieder mit einem Maus wackeln anmachen können.
Naja, vielleicht fühlt er sich ja auch dadurch, dass er sich ausschaltet.
Auf jeden Fall, weil die LEDs erzeugen ja...
Aber du kannst ihn sofort, wenn er ausgeht, kannst du ihn sofort wieder machen.
Ja, das mag er dann mit irgendwelchen Threshold-Sachen, dass wenn er sich einschaltet, dass er dann nicht sofort wieder aktiv sich ausschaltet.
Aber solange du die ganze Zeit mit der Maus wackelst, passiert trotzdem, ja? Du sitzt davor, du machst Dinge mit der Maus, Tastatur etc.
Du geht da irgendwann auch aus.
Dann wackelst du aber weiter und dann geht er wieder an?
Nein, es ist nur diese Active Corner, dieses explizite Triggern von G aus dem Ruhezustand wieder raus. Das hilft dann. Nicht das reine Bewegen der Maus. Ich rede nicht vom Screen Saver, ich rede von dem Ruhezustand. Ja, habe ich gebraucht gekauft. Das Ding ist leider nicht top. Also schaltet sich auch Bluetooth ab. Also der ist so ein bisschen on its way out, glaube ich. Aber es ist ein bisschen schneller, als mir jetzt lieb gewesen wäre.
Also wie gesagt, du kannst mit iStat Menus sehr schön sämtliche Temperatursensoren sehen.
Das stimmt.
Und er sagt dir auch, wie schnell die Lüfte, von denen er es weiß, sich drehen.
Das werde ich mal überprüfen. Wir könnten zum nächsten Thema fortschreiten.
Schreit, schreit.
Also ich habe so einen USB-C-to-HDMI-Adapter, der halt auch nach zwei Stunden so heiß ist, dass der Monitor dunkel wird. Der Adapter wird so heiß.
USB-C-to-HDMI, also sozusagen nicht passive, sondern richtig aktiver Adapter.
Ja, ich habe da ein 4K-Monitor dran.
Das ist alles aktiv.
Der wird ordentlich warm.
Hast du diesen von Club3D?
Nee, der ist nicht von Club3D.
Aber er kann 4K.
Der kann 4K.
Weil mein alter Konter, habe ich ja mal berichtet hier, der konnte keine 4K. Und dann musste ich mir den von Club3D holen, der konnte dann 4K.
Nö, das geht. Und wenn man ab und zu anfasst, sodass die Wärme quasi in die Hand abfließen kann, dann schaltet der sich auch nicht aus. Also das geht dann schon. Beziehungsweise fängt er manchmal an zu blinken, da weiß man, oh, jetzt ist er wieder warm.
Also hatte ich mit meinem noch nicht, und ich hab einen von Club3D, und der tut so ein kleiner, schwarzer. Der funktioniert super.
Freak Show-Berichtete.
Meiner ist glaube ich von Amker.
Nee, ich hab auch diesen 3D, den hatte ja Huckel irgendwann mal empfohlen.
Oder beide?
Ich hab mir auf jeden Fall ein Stapel von diesen Club3D-Dingern geholt, weil in der Firma wurde ganz früh diese neuen MacBooks und dann gleich die tollen Displays, also die tollen Anführungsstrichen, die die 4K haben und USB-C-Laden gekauft und dann haben die Kollegen Probleme gehabt mit den anderen Displays, die kein USB-C haben und dann wurden schon ganz viele Adapter ausprobiert und dann hat sich relativ schnell schon rauskristallisiert, dass diese Club3D länger als drei Tage halten. Ich glaub einer der Kollegen auch hat einfach mal so zwei, drei bestellt.
Okay, naja, das andere wäre halt einfach ein USB-C auf Display-Port-Kabel zu nehmen. Das geht ja.
Ja, kommt, das ist ja das Gleiche am Ende. Display-Port und HDMI ist ja mehr oder weniger das Gleiche. Das braucht nur einen passiven Adapter. Das muss das Gleiche sein, eigentlich mehr oder weniger.
Ja, aber aus irgendeinem Grund. Das Kabel wird halt nicht warm. Der Adapter wird warm. Keine Ahnung, was der tut.
Vielleicht noch mal irgendwie Längen verstärken. Dann lass mich doch jetzt kurz über die Grafikkarte erzählen, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind, ne, Timme?
Pimp My Mac.
Ja, lang, stimmt.
So lange das Soundboard noch geht, bitte.
Das haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gehabt, ne?
Ja, dann hau mal rein.
Muss erstmal vom Magnetband geholt werden.
Der Roboter muss doch in die Keller runterfahren. So, hier Huckel. Du hast mich ja auch schon mal angerufen, hat gefragt, was geht dann so an bessere Grafikkarte, weil du willst ordentlich zocken in der Mac Pro, richtig? Und ich hab gesagt, schwierig, schwierig, nicht so richtig. Und die scheiß Ethereum Miner und so machen die Preise so teuer und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, es gibt halt seit, weiß nicht, wann die Karte rauskam, schon vor einem halben Jahr oder so, gibt's ja von AMD die Vega Serie, die es als 56 und auch als 64 gibt. Die 64 verbraucht ein bisschen sehr viel Bums, ist aber die rechts unten Karte, aber die kannst du einfach in ein Mac Pro nicht reinpacken.
Weil zu viel Strom.
Weil kostet zu viel Strom, außer du betreibst sie dauerhaft mit einem externen Netzteil, was geht. Also man kann ja die Grafikkarte einfach mit dem Strom von einem anderen Netzteil so plopp plopp und dann kann man das natürlich machen. Dann geht das wahrscheinlich wunderbar. Das wollte ich aber nicht. Ich wollte ja meine 280X, die ich hab, Freak Show berichtete, wollte ich ablösen. Das heißt, Deckel zu, sollte kleiner sein, sich selber mit Strom versorgen. Am besten weniger Strom verbrauchen, als die 280X dabei mehr Bums haben. Ich wollte mehr Bums pro Watt, könnte man sagen. Also insgesamt mehr Bums. Ja, doch, auch will man natürlich auch ein bisschen haben. Aber so ein bisschen effektiver auch, dachte ich. Und dann dachte ich, ach ja, jetzt scheiß drauf. Ich brauche jetzt hier so eine Vega 56. Jetzt reicht es. Preise sind immer noch gar nicht schön teuer. Aber ich sehe die Reminder und so kaufen die wohl wie blöd. Und bin ich einfach los, habe mir die geholt. Ich bin hier bei Case King, da irgendwo im Wedding, oder wo die da sind, bin da direkt hin. Die hatten auch gerade umgebaut, habe ich meine Cola umsonst bekommen, weil Eröffnung und so, keine Ahnung. Und habe mir die geben lassen, bin nach Hause, reingepackt in den Mac, gebootet. Und du kommst ja erst mal, du kriegst ja kein Bild, keinen Bootscreen, weil die alte Karte musst du ja erst mal rausmachen. Und mein Trick war immer so, blind dann, ich wusste ja genau, wie mein Rechner bootet, so erst mal Cursor links, return, um irgendwie meinen User auszuwählen, weil da sind zwei. Dann sozusagen blind Passwort eingeben, return, eine Weile warten und wenn der Treiber dann geladen wird, dann schwupp, kommt ein Bild. War schon mal nicht, dachte ich. Und dann bin ich, habe ich natürlich so eine, ich habe die kleine NVIDIA GT120 noch. Das ist so eine ganz kleine, die verbraucht doch nicht viel Platz. Hab die zusätzlich noch mit reingepackt, die an den Monitor angeschlossen, damit ich einen Bootscreen kriege. Hab dann mich eingeloggt, das ging dann auch. Und dann Plop Bild Bild, also auf beiden. Auch mit der neuen Karte wusste ich schon mal, ok, das geht. Aber die Karte hatte natürlich kein Mini DisplayPort mehr. Deswegen musste ich dann nochmal warten, bis gestern oder vorgestern, bis der Mini DisplayPort Buchse auf DisplayPort Stecker kam, was dann in die Karte reingeht, damit ich erstmal meinen Standard Monitor da anschließen kann. Das ging schon mal super. Problem ist, glaube ich, immer noch, ich brauch immer noch diese Zweitkarte, damit ich blind mich einloggen kann. Da muss auch gar kein Monitor dranstecken, aber diese Karte muss leider im Rechner sein. Das muss ich noch irgendwie gefixt kriegen, das gefällt mir noch nicht so. Und heute kamen dann auch nochmal Stromkabel, weil der Mac Pro hat ja diese Mini-Anschlüsse, die dann auf größere PCI-Anschlüsse gehen, was dann in die Grafikkarte reingeht. Das sind ja sogenannte PCI-Stromanschlüsse, weiß nicht, wie die genau heißen, weil diese Karte hat zwei Mal 8 PIN, und die vorherige Karte hatte nur einmal 6 PIN und einmal 8 PIN. Und 6 PIN heißt 75 Watt, 8 PIN heißt 150 Watt. Und das habe ich irgendwann mal probiert, und dann machst du mal so Tests, und dann machst du plopp, Rechner aus. Scheiße. Und das ist aber so ein Sicherheitsfaktor oder Schutz, der, wenn zu viel Ampere über die Leitung geht, dann schaltet sich der Rechner aus, sozusagen ist gar kein Problem. Ziehst du kurz den Stecker aus dem Gerät, lässt ihn 30 Sekunden stehen, steckst den Stecker wieder rein, hat er sich resettet, dann kannst du ihn auch wieder einschalten. Das ist einfach nur so eine Schutzsicherung, die da irgendwie zuschlägt. Und ich hab mal gemessen über dieses externe Netzteil. Das Ding zieht tatsächlich komplette 150 Watt pro achtfach Stecker. Und ich meine, wir haben eigentlich diese kleinen Dinge, die wir haben, sind nur diese sechsfach Stecker. Da kommen eigentlich nur 75 Watt raus. Also das heißt, die werden doppelt so krass belastet, wie man sollte. Das heißt, eigentlich geht es nicht. Aber diese Karte hat so einen kleinen Bios-Schalter. Damit kann man in so einen Stromspar-Bios schalten. Und dann zieht sie halt nicht mehr ganz so viel Bums. Also sie verbraucht 15 Prozent oder so weniger. Aber von der Performance geht das nur 4 Prozent runter. Wie das ja am Ende mal so ist. Du brauchst ja viel Bums für noch wenig extra. Und dann denkt man sich, okay, die paar Prozent kann ich mir jetzt auch schenken, die brauche ich nicht. Hab also den Schalter umgelegt und siehe da, das tut, also das geht. Das heißt also dieses Riesenmonster, das ist wirklich ein Riesenmonster, die ist auch nach oben breiter. Das ist ja so ein schmaler Streifen im Mac Pro, der so nach oben geht und der nutzt den einfach aus. Das ist krass und auch bis nach hinten ran. Also ich glaube wirklich physikalisch, da geht jetzt nichts mehr. Das ist wirklich jetzt wirklich am Ende. Und also es heißt, der Mac Pro kann das Ding bei meiner Karte jedenfalls da komplett selbst versorgen. Hab ich gecheckt, das geht. Der Adapter für Mini DisplayPort, was man beim Cinema Display braucht, den muss man sich schon holen, außer man nutzt direkt HDMI, dann ist es egal. Aber ich hab mir diesen Adapter besorgt, geht also auch. Was halt noch nicht geht, ist, ich muss immer noch diese GT120 drin lassen, damit ich halt mich einloggen kann. Ich mach das zwar auch blind, da muss kein Monitor dran sein, aber den muss man halt haben. Ich hätte die Karte gerne noch ganz los. Weiß ich noch nicht, wie ich das irgendwie hinkriegen kann. Vielleicht kann man das noch mit so einem Pseudo-Bios hinschummeln. Dass da so ein Bios irgendwas so tut, als ob. Ich muss ja kein Bild kriegen, aber der Rechner muss denken, da wäre schon was, dass es mich Passwort eintippen lässt. Das ist eigentlich alles. Und das wäre noch schon schön, weil blind tippen ist jetzt nicht so schlimm. Einmal im Jahr, weil wir legen unsere Rechner eh nur schlafen. Oder machst du den Rechner aus?
Ich mach den weg voraus, weil der im Sleep-Modus mir immer noch zu viel strumpft.
Wie viel zieht der, wenn er schläft? Ich hab gar nicht geguckt. 9 Watt, oder?
Viel, nee, richtig viel.
Hab ich doch geguckt, so viel war's doch gar nicht.
Also bei mir war das, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz doll vertue, aber schon so in Richtung 100.
Sleep-Mode?
Also es war so was wie 60, 80.
Das hätte ich auch gemerkt, dann würde ich das nicht machen.
Spint der dann die Disks nicht dauernd?
Nein, ich hab ja noch meinen Display, das ist dann wahrscheinlich noch nicht im Power-Safe-Modus, das ist ja auch noch an der Dose dran.
Den Display hab ich extra gemessen, das zählt nicht. Ich hatte eine Weile, ganze letzte Jahre, ich hab dauerhaft mein Strommessgerät an meinem Mac Pro dran.
Ich guck mal, was die Speck sagt.
Guck mal, was die Speck sagt. Jedenfalls, das geht alles. Was schön ist an der Karte, wenn sie ganz langsam läuft, sozusagen gar nichts zu tun hat, dann gehen die Lüfter sogar einfach aus, weil untenrum verbraucht das so fast nichts, dass die Lüfter einfach stehen bleiben. Also es ist wirklich sehr leise, wenn nichts los ist. Auch wohl ist er eine Treibergeschichte, aber die updaten das bei den alten Karten nicht. Deswegen könnte man schon sagen, das haben nur die neueren Vega-Karten oder so. Das, wenn du Videos abspielst, das erkennen die Karten und fahren dann nicht mehr so krass hoch, weil sie wissen, sie brauchen zwar vielleicht immer so einen kleinen Burst an Power Pro Bild oder irgendwie so, aber insgesamt eigentlich nicht so viel. Das heißt, auch bei Videos abspielen geht der Verbrauch fast gar nicht hoch, weil sich die Karte dafür nicht unbedingt hochtaktet, weil sie weiß, sie kriegt das auch mit einem geringeren Takt irgendwie berechnet. Und also sie ist schon sparsamer insgesamt.
Ist das die von März 2018 oder?
Die Karte, die ich habe, ich sage jetzt nicht, von welcher Firma ich die habe, ich habe eine AMD Vega von einer bestimmten Vude, aber welche, ist ja eigentlich wurscht. Das sehe ich bei dir da auch nicht. Aber würde ich ihr nicht sehen können, kann ich nicht erkennen. Nee, aber es gibt ja ganz viele verschiedene.
Achso, da steht es ja, alles klar.
Es gibt ja ganz viele verschiedene bei denen.
Und wie viel toller ist jetzt als die 280?
50% würde ich sagen. Also wenn du vorher 30 Frames hast, dann hast du jetzt 45.
Ja, doch.
Ich finde, das ist schon ordentlich. Vor allem muss man mal sehen, wenn man so Games spielt, dann kannst du einstellen, ich brauche nicht mehr als 60 Frames die Sekunde. Und dann kannst du sagen, wenn es 60 Frames die Sekunde ist, dann braucht er nicht mehr machen. Und das heißt, die Karte ist jetzt viel einfacher dabei, diese 60 Frames zu erreichen. Und bremst sich dadurch auch öfter wiederum ab, weil es erreicht ist und er dann nicht schneller machen muss. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt sparsamer sogar ist als vorher. Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall, ja, flutscht das viel besser und ist öfter an einem Limit, wo die Karte dann wieder ein bisschen auf langsamer machen kann, weil mehr soll sie ja nicht tun.
Und hast du die jetzt aber auch schon mal so richtig durchglühen lassen mit so...
Na, glühen noch nicht. Aber ich habe ja hier, glaube ich, habe ich auch schon mal von erzählt, diesen Vanity Generator, der so Bitcoin Vanity Adressen generieren kann. Und den habe ich halt, als das externe Netzteil dran war. Das Ding zieht wirklich die kompletten 300 Watt. Oder wenn man halt diesen kleinen Schalter umlegt, noch 250 Watt. Also der zieht wirklich volle Pulle. Und jetzt läuft es über die Stromversorgung, die direkt vom Mac kommt. Und da habe ich das dann auch gemacht. Und der Rechner ist nicht ausgegangen. Also das heißt, das ist sozusagen das Hardcore, mehr geht nicht als mit diesen Tools. Und kein Game dieser Welt wird so einen krassen Stromverbrauch haben, wie diese Tools, weil die einfach so gleichmäßig und sauber da am Performance-Limit kratzen, um alles, um das Bestmöglichste rauszuholen. Das kriegen die Spieler einfach nicht hin. Und wollen wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht.
Also das, was auch immer das G3D Mark ist, Geek 3D, keine Ahnung, da ist er doppelt so schnell wie die 280X, bei 2D nur ein bisschen schneller.
Weiß nicht ganz sein. Ich hab da so ein paar Sachen gebenchmarkt, also zum Beispiel bei dem Hashcat, das ist so ein Passwörter-Cracking-Tool, der hatte ich bei MD5, ne MD5 war es glaube ich nicht, das ist irgendwas anders. Den Algorithmus, der von den Bitcoin Wallets benutzt wird, du kennst ja warum ich das mache, ist das das, der? Ja kann sein, da bin ich jedenfalls von 12.200 Hashes die Sekunde auf 17.800 gekommen. Das war aber wiederum mit der schnellen Einstellung, ich hab ja die langsamere, das waren dann 16.800 oder so, weil sonst macht der Mac das wahrscheinlich nicht mit.
Na gut, also falls ich mal doch nochmal ein bisschen mehr Grafikpower haben will, dann...
Ja für alle, die da ein bisschen budgetmäßig mehr orientiert sind, würde ich jetzt noch ein, zwei Monate warten, bis die Miner sich da wieder verdrückt haben aus dem Grafikkartenmarkt, damit die Preise noch ein bisschen weiter purzeln. Die sind ja schon ganz gut gepurzelt, aber noch längst nicht genug eigentlich. Also wer noch ein bisschen Geduld hat, das aussetzen, vielleicht warten, bis wieder die nächste Generation kommt, weil die kommt ja sicher bestimmt. Aber die Vega geht jetzt gerade so gut, auch wirklich ohne Fehler, ohne alles. Und ohne Bootbildschirm. Aber sie geht halt treibermäßig, weil sie ja glaube ich im iMac Pro verbaut ist, richtig? Deswegen ist der Treibersupport so da und so gut.
Muss jetzt noch jemand mal die Firmware da?
Das ist glaube ich nicht so einfach, weil die haben doch was umgestellt, und so hat einer mal geschrieben, sonst hätten die das ja schon längst gemacht. Ich glaube, es geht einfach gar nicht mehr, so umzustellen.
Kurzer Nachtrag, also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, aber so wie ich das jetzt hier rausgelesen habe, ist der Sleep Mode so 8 Watt oder so was der größte Ordnung.
Ja, das geht doch aber.
So war das zumindest 2007er Modell?
Ja, ich denke in dem Bereich war es so. Sonst würde ich meinen Rechner nicht anlassen, wenn der mehr als 20 Watt für braucht. Ich bin auch schon ein ganz schöner Stromsparer. Nicht wenn die Kisten an sind, dann ist mir egal. Wenn ich am zocken bin, dann gib ihm. Aber wenn die Scheiße aus ist, dann finde ich soll die Scheiße aus sein.
Ja, ich habe hier auch großflächig Zwischenschalter, die so komplette Subnetze rausnehmen, damit man einfach den Strom runtergefahren bekommt. Das einzige, was hier wirklich dauerhaft läuft, ist mein Kühlschrank.
Ja, und der geht ja auch an und aus und so weiter.
Ich habe übrigens ein bisschen den Gedanken durch meinen Kopf geschoben, ob nicht vielleicht der iMac Pro für mich doch eine Option sein könnte.
Ja, eine Option ist es immer. Er sagt nicht Alternative. Eine wählbare Option.
Ja, also.
Eine veritable.
Ob ich das sozusagen...
Tun solltest.
Genau.
Ja, kurzfristig ist das bestimmt super cool alles. Auf langfristig weiß ich nicht, ob das so meins wäre.
Was meinst du damit?
Na kurzfristig ist das irgendwie top Power, top Bildschirm, top alles. Ein, zwei Jahre geht das gut, aber dann will man irgendwie mehr und erweitern oder was, ein bisschen updaten oder irgendwie so Einzelteile sich ein bisschen verbessern. Und das geht mit dem Ding aber nicht.
Ja gut, aber ich hab... Was für Einzelteile verbessern?
Du willst in zwei Jahren plötzlich mehr Grafikpower haben. Was machst du denn?
Verkaufen, neu kaufen. Also die finanzielle Aspekt gleich nochmal hinterher. Ich hab mir auch ein paar Gedanken zugemacht. Aber zunächst einmal war für mich die Frage, könnte ich das überhaupt?
Ja, stimmt, natürlich.
Also könnte ein iMac Pro mein Mac Pro ersetzen? Und natürlich auch die Frage, ist er schnell genug? Die Frage ist noch nicht abschließend geklärt.
Schnell genug müsste er sein.
Schnell genug, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass es sich lohnt. Also, dass ich einen nenne.
Da du ja letztens mal aufgepimpt hast, hast du die Latte ja schon ganz schön hochgelegt. Aber ich denke, so ein iMac der aktuelle, der haut das Ding da aus dem Wasser.
Ja, die Frage ist, mit was und was davon ist für mich wirklich wichtig.
Brauchst du Grafik-Performance oder CPU-Performance? Beide Frage.
Ich brauch Render-Performance, Audio-Render-Performance.
Ja, aber läuft das Audio-Rendern denn auf der Grafikkarte?
Es läuft auf dem ganzen System. Es läuft auf dem Bus, es läuft auf der CPU, es läuft auf der...
Aber läuft es auf der Grafikkarte?
Nein. Aber die CPU ist ja auch schneller.
Ja klar, aber die Frage ist, ob du eine fette Grafikkarte brauchst. Zum Beispiel. Eigentlich brauchst du die gar nicht.
Nein, brauch ich nicht. Also ich hab keine... Die einzige 3D-Anforderung, die ich habe, ist Google Earth.
Das muss irgendwie...
Und deine Bildschirm, du hast dann irgendwie zwei oder drei da dran, das muss irgendwie wenigstens flutschen, aber das ist das, was der iMac Pro eingebaut hat, der tut das.
Genau, der hat ja da ordentlich viel Thunderbolt-Ausgänge, da kann man sowas schon anschließen. Das wäre sozusagen alles gegeben. Dann... halt viel von allem.
Was ist der kleinste Kern, den man sich da holen kann?
8-Core, 3,2 Gigahertz.
Ja, ich glaube, der kickt dein Mac Pro schon in den Hintern.
Ja, die Frage ist nur, kann die Software das auch nutzen? Ich hab zum Beispiel diesen skurrilen Effekt, den ich mir immer noch nicht erklären kann, dass wenn ich jetzt in Reaper mein Audiokram rausrendere, dann langweilt sich die CBO.
Das Problem, ja, verstehe.
Und ich frage mich, warum langweilt sich die CPU?
Auch nicht eine einzig geläuft auf 100%?
Nee, nee. Das verteilt sich über mehrere CPUs. Und ich frage mich immer so, okay, also wenn die CPU nicht die ganze Zeit was zu tun hat, worauf wartet sie dann?
Ajo, am Platt, aber das Thema hatten wir doch schon mal hier in der Sendung, oder? Wir sind da nicht so richtig vorwärts gekommen.
Genau, die Frage ist, wie die Software geschrieben ist, weil es kann ja sein, dass du...
Dass du Pausen anlegst zwischendurch?
Nee, nee, dass du gar nicht bezahlt hast.
Also mir ist das bei NoteJS-Gedöns aufgefallen, dass du nur einen bestimmten Teil an Speicher zum Beispiel belegen kannst, dann bekommst du eine Buffer-Overflow-Exception oder so einen Krampel. Und kann es sein, dass es da was Ähnliches gibt, dass du...
Wie man kann nur einen bestimmten Teil an Speichern belegen?
Bei NoteJS hast du eine Angabe drin, dass du nicht über den Arbeitsspeicher gehen darfst, ich weiß nicht, wie groß das maximal ist, aber das ist beschränkt bei NoteJS. Ja, mir ist halt auch...
Aber Moment mal, NoteJS und Performance sind...
Also an der Stelle brauchen wir nicht weiter zu diskutieren. Aber ich meine, die Frage ist ja auch...
Ich hab nur vercheckt, worin das da geschrieben ist.
Genau, das ist halt die Frage, in was ist es geschrieben und gibt es da eine ähnliche Restriktion, die sowas hervorrufen?
Also, ich kann schon mal sagen, ich hatte diesen Effekt mal, aber ich hab ihn sehr lange schon nicht mehr. Also bei mir ballert der Reaper volle Lotte raus.
Alle CPUs sind voll beschäftigt?
Also, der macht ja pro Spur gefüllt einen Kernfolder, ne? Und ich hab selten acht Spuren.
Wenn du rausrenderst, du hast nur sechs Kerne.
Bei Flak hab ich jetzt noch... Ich renn ja selten in Flak raus. Das kann dich morgen noch mal anschreiben.
Aber wie kann der nicht die volle CPU belegen?
Das muss IO sein, dann...
Ja, aber der schreibt auf SSD.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Der schreibt da auch ganz...
Der schreibt da in Tempfall, dann Tempfall liegt noch auf Platte oder sowas.
Trittest nur bei Flak auf.
Hast du noch Spinning Rust überhaupt da drin?
Ja, aber der schreibt alles auf. Trittest nur bei Flak auf?
Hast du schon mal was anderes getestet wie AIF oder was?
Das solltest du mal versuchen. Also es kann natürlich sein, dass der Flak-Codex so schlecht geschrieben ist, dass er sich selbst deadlockt und auf Locks wartet. Und einfach dadurch, dass halt verschiedene Sachen auf verschiedenen Kernen aufeinander warten, kann es halt einfach dazu führen, dass nichts passiert.
Und dass man das ein Prozess 100% auf einer CPU nicht sieht, weil er es auf mehrere CPUs verteilt, aber alle Module immer oder Streads auf die anderen warten, bis die fertig sind. Und deswegen, dass zwar verteilt ist, aber insgesamt trotzdem nur 100% ergibt und nicht mehr als 100%.
Das ist halt nur nicht worauf er da warten soll.
Ja, schlechtes Software, da erkläre ich das nicht.
Und Flak werden sie nicht selber implementiert haben, sondern wahrscheinlich irgendwas aus...
Der Standard-Lib von irgendwo.
M-Player oder M-Pack.
Da werde ich mir nicht so sicher, aber ich glaube eher, dass sie das selber implementiert haben.
Naja, das F im Namen, egal.
Reaper nimmt in Flak auf.
Kann in Flak aufnehmen, standardmäßig nicht.
Tut es gerade, es wird alles in Flak direkt live auf die Platte gezeigt.
Man muss ja gar nicht mehr rennen.
Ja, aber dann muss er ja umzurendern. Muss er ja Flak dekodieren, das zusammenmischen und es dann nach Flak wieder rausrendern. Und wenn der Flak-Codec ein Problem hat.
Kann er ja gerne mitmachen.
Ja, aber wenn der Flak ein Problem hat.
Mit was?
Ja, wissen wir doch noch nicht.
Nein, ich sag ja, mit Deadlocks. Multi-Empreading-Fähigkeit. Deswegen versuch's mal mit...
Mit Mütlichkeit.
Mit A-F-F oder irgendwas.
Waff.
Aber mit was anderem, mit Waff, was anderem als Flak. Ob du den gleichen Effekt auch hast.
Weil ich hab nämlich, ich nehm immer ein Waff auf, was so der Standard da ja in der Einstellung ist und renn dann gelegentlich auch mal nach Flak oder MP3 raus.
Weil es geht.
Warum nicht? Flak ist ja auch nur 40% kleiner.
Warum nicht? Du rierst komplett die Realität des Audiorecordings. Das ist Faktor 10 kleiner. Ja, wenn du Recording machst, weil du halt viel stiller hast und du kriegst einfach ex-orbitant viel kleinere Projektweise.
Timme, wir sehen das alles ein. Es geht ja auch nicht um zu optimieren, das kommt später. Wir wollen erst mal den Fehler finden. Und wenn der Fehler flak ist, finden wir den nur raus, wenn du mal was anderes probierst.
Wenn du das dann auch scheißt, kannst du wieder zurück-switchen. Deswegen erwähne ich das ja gerade. Es kann ja sein, dass die Software Fehler hat. Ich würde trotzdem dasselbe von ihr wollen.
Aber deswegen kannst du dich noch dem Test nicht verweigern.
Tja, also ich doch nicht.
Ich auch gar nicht.
Ich verweige mich überhaupt nichts.
Ich teste das und schreibe dann einen Bug-Report.
Ja oder halt auch nicht.
Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, dass dieser CPU-Teil natürlich nur ein Aspekt ist. Der andere Aspekt ist, dass ich ja auch noch PCI-Karten habe in meinem Mac Pro, die nicht von der modernen Hardware des iMac aufgewogen werden.
Das ist kein Problem. Du holst dir so ein externes GPU-Gehäuse, steckst nur die GPU nicht rein, sondern deine Audio-Karte rum, fertig.
Welches?
Dann schreibst du dann deinem Audio-Kartenhersteller, ob denn das geht. Und dann so, ja, und dann kriegst du so eine Antwort, wie du sie immer von Audio-Herstellern bekommst. Aber mit dem Hersteller gab es wohl Probleme. So wie was es gab da Probleme und worin unterscheiden die sich? Einerseits glaube ich das nicht, andererseits weiß ich es nicht. Dann bin ich in den Apple Store reingeladen, gelaufen und hab irgendwie...
Lass mal in den Apple Store.
Laufen.
Hast du der Kopfhörer getauscht? Was man halt mal so tut. Moment, ich reise viel.
Ja, natürlich!
Ich stelle immer die gleiche Frage. Ihr wisst auch welche.
Ob sie mir noch einen MacBook Air 11 Zoll verkaufen können. Und wenn sie sagen nein, sag ich warum nicht.
Das hast du letztes Mal schon erzählt.
Das werde ich auch weiterhin tun, so lange bis es ist. Und ich kann dir sagen, ich kriege auch hinter vorgehaltener Hand höchstes Verständnis für meine Situation. Und das ist sozusagen durchaus etwas, was diskutiert wird in diesen Kreisen. Und das ist da angekommen, dass diese Computer nicht mehr populär sind und dass alle Leute darauf kotzen. Und ich habe auch versprochen, weiterhin dieses Outlet hier zu nutzen, um darauf so lange herumzuraten, bis sich das ändert. Macht richtige Computer, die wir geil finden.
Apple könnte nicht einfach so einen Teil mal wo auskuddeln und hier hinschicken.
Macht einen Computer, den ich geil finde.
Macht einen Computer, den er geil findet, und für uns macht er was Schickes.
Ihr könnt auch drei Computer machen. Weißt du, was ich dann mache? Dann kaufe ich die alle drei sofort. Auf jeden Fall habe ich dann gefragt, wie denn das so ist mit externen Gehäusen und ob sie da irgendwie meine Liste haben oder so irgendwas empfehlen können.
Die haben doch Empfehlungen rausgegeben.
Im Apple Store wissen sie nichts. Wo haben sie Empfehlungen rausgegeben?
Na, für ihre GPU haben sie eine Standardempfehlung rausgegeben.
Oder Roddy?
Was denn? Sonnet oder sowas?
Ja, du kannst die GPU glaube ich gleich in dem Gehäuse kaufen.
Sonnet, seit wann verkaufen die denn in Europa?
Keine Ahnung. Aber jetzt inzwischen gibt es so viele externe Gehäuse, das ist ja Standard, weil die PC-Jungs machen das bestimmt auch demnächst. Das ist Standard. Das ist immer das Schöne, wenn der Standard so auf Apple einschlägt und dann du auch immer merkst, was da plötzlich so an Preisen geht. Ich hab mir gerade einen USB-C 2,5 Zoll SATA Adapter schnuffig gekauft. 8 Euro. Und Plastik hab ich weggeschmissen, hab nur die Platine aufgehoben, weil nur die interessiert mich, weil ich hab das immer gerne so einzeln, aber das sind immer Preise, oder? Ich glaub, ich hätte bei denen letztens sogar eine Webseite gesehen, wo sie verschiedene Kombinationen empfehlen. Und die Seite war von Apple.
235 Euro für......
ein PC-Gehäuse.
Zwei Slots.
Zwei?
Das ist aber ein guter Preis.
Mit Netzteil oder ohne Netzteil?
Das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt hab, war es ungefähr 400 für einen Slot.
Sag ich ja, die PC-Preise, die nutzen das auch langsam, sondern gehen die Preise runter.
Desktop-Gehäuse-Karten halbe Länge und volle Bauhöhe.
Halbe Länge? Nee, dann ist für'n Arsch. Kriegst ja gar keine Grafikkarte rein.
Er will ja auch keine Grafikkarte reinmachen.
Naja, vielleicht auch, doch.
Oder du willst doch diese, diese...
Audio-Karte, klar, ich will da meine Audio... Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich grad nicht, wie lang das Ding ist. Aber ich glaub nicht volle Länge, eher kürzer. Nee, das ist halbe Länge.
Das könnte prima aus dem Kontext reißen, meinst du? Passt schon, weitermachen.
Also, und du meinst, Apple empfiehlt das?
Mir war so. Ich bin der Meinung, es gab sogar eine Seite von Apple, wo sie Grafikkarten empfehlen, welche gehen, und die Gehäuse empfehlen, und welche Gehäuse man mit welcher Karte mischen kann, weil die haben ja alle so ein bisschen andere Power-Anforderungen, dass du halt nicht dir die fetteste Grafikkarte für das kleinste Gehäuse holst und so weiter. Also, ja, und sie sagen sogar, was man womit wie laden kann. Also, die haben ja auch so Ladefähigkeiten.
So, dann muss ich mir jetzt mal so einen iMac zusammenklicken, mal gucken, was man so bezahlt.
Sehr viel, wenn du es drauf anlegst. Sehr, sehr viel. Also, das ist irgendwie völlig unklar.
Brauchst du überhaupt einen neuen Rechner? Anstatt fixen du lieber mal dein Flaggproblem und dann flutscht das auch.
Tim braucht die große Lösung.
Genau. Und danach performt es immer noch nicht und dann war es wirklich nur Flagg.
Das Ding ist, Macs kosten ja kein Geld. Die kosten ja nichts.
Es gibt Leute da draußen, die da widersprechen.
Ich weiß, aber die liegen ja falsch. Na guck mal, wenn du dir jetzt so ein iMac kaufst.
Kommst du jetzt mit deiner Abschreibungstaktik um die Ecke?
Für 10.000 Euro. Ja, so. Dann zahlst du schon mal irgendwie.
Jetzt kommt der Buchhalter-Trick.
Und zahlst du schon mal 40 Prozent nicht steuern. Also je nach deiner Steuerklasse natürlich, aber wenn du sozusagen in so einem Business-Flow bist, klar kannst du es absetzen.
Nur als Freiberufler oder Freelancer. Das heißt, der Rest der Leute, die uns zuhören, gerade nicht.
Der Rest der Leute, die uns zuhören, wollen sie auch keine iMac Pro kaufen, weil das ist ja für Pros. Gut, ja. Was kommt jetzt? Kulturkritik oder was?
Ne, mach weiter.
Ich rede jetzt aus dem Kontext heraus, man verdient mit dem Kram sein Geld. Wenn du so einen Computer kaufst, dann kannst du den auch abschreiben.
Du hast auch kein Programm.
Wenn du Angestellter bist, dann kaufst du den eh nicht selber. Du kaufst den als Selbstständiger oder als Business Owner. Es gibt ja genug Leute, die selbstständig sind.
Jetzt haben wir jetzt weiterhins.
Umsatzsteuer geht da schonmal runter. Dann hast du eine Steuerspanne, die sich auf drei Jahre verteilt. Du schreibst das Ding über drei Jahre ab. So, spart dir halt entsprechend Steuern. So, geht also schonmal. Ein Großteil dieses Geldes gewinnst du quasi durch es nicht ausgeben an den Staat. 60% des Preises. Ein iMac Pro im Vollausbau in drei Jahren erzielt auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt 60% seines Preises. Die kriegst du. Das Ding geht nicht kaputt. Wenn du es nicht irgendwie vom Tisch schmeißt, du kannst da Apple Care noch drauf werfen, die dann für drei Jahre gelten. Das Teil ist danach in Ordnung. Und guck mal, was diese alten, gammeligen Mac Pros, die wir jetzt haben, die Cheese Graters, immer noch auf eBay aufrufen, weil die Leute dahinterher sind. Das hier ist ein ordentlicher Computer, dieser iMac Pro. Der ist in drei Jahren sitzen die Leute gierig vor eBay und sagen, ich will jetzt so einen scheiß iMac Pro. Jetzt kommen die nämlich endlich mal in den Preisbereich, wo ich mir die leisten kann. 60 Prozent des eigentlichen Preises. So, nach drei Jahren ist das Ding abgeschrieben, kannst du privat übernehmen, kannst du irgendwie steuerfrei verkaufen. Endpreis 0 Euro.
Das ist einfach mal so.
Ja, aber musst du denn, wenn du den verkaufst, musst du das ja wieder als Einnahmen verbuchen.
Nein, wenn er abgeschrieben ist, kannst du ihn ausbuchen.
Ist ja ein schöner Steuertrick, aber...
Das ist kein Steuertrick, das ist normal. Normalerweise sind die Computer nach drei Jahren halt nix mehr wert. Nur so ein Apple Highend-Teil ist nach drei Jahren noch was wert. Und zwar viel wert. Du brauchst nur auf eBay nach drei Jahren alten Highend-Computern schauen und gucken, was du dafür ausgehen musst. Und das ist eine ganze Menge. Du zahlst für so einen Scheißteil nichts.
Das ist einfach mal der Preis.
Und dann könnt ihr mit 1000 Mark kommen mit eurem das ist ja aber so teuer und so. Die sind nicht teuer.
Aber ich kann auch andere Sachen kaufen, mit denen ich den gleichen Steuertricks mache. Das heißt, man muss sich aber überlegen, was man erholt. Das heißt, am Ende sind es trotzdem 5.500 Euro Einstiegspreis.
Ja, aber du kriegst ja komplett wieder. Du musst ja nur 3 Jahre vorschießen.
du hast halt am Ende nichts bezahlt. Kostet halt nichts. Und wenn du dann vielleicht 500 Euro Differenz hast in dieser ganzen Rechnung oder 1000, hast du den Top of the Line, High End, super geiler Bildschirme performt, ordentlich sieht es sogar noch geil aus und hat einen schwarzen Tastaturcomputer 3 Jahre auf deinem Tisch gehabt. Und es hat dich irgendwie 10 Euro im Monat gekostet.
In der übernächsten Sendung hat Tim hier so ein neues Ding.
Die Tastatur ist aber die scheiß Tastatur.
Die Tastatur tauscht man aus, die legt man irgendwo weg, damit sie nicht zerkratzt und du machst dir die gute. Lass mich kurz zitieren.
1280 glaube ich.
Mein Augenlicht.
Nee, weißt du nicht.
Ich glaube 1242. A1242.
Ja, so eine habe ich von einem netten Hörer auch.
Ich auch. Wer auch immer mir das geschickt hat, danke.
Ja, danke.
Und falls irgendjemand noch A1242 Tastaturen umrumliegen hat, Her damit. Die beste Tastatur der Welt.
Die großen mit Kabel, die gab es ja bis vor kurzem auch immer noch zu kaufen, die sind ja mein Favorit.
Ja, da habe ich noch.
Davon habe ich auch noch zwei in.
Ich habe noch drei eingepackte zu Hause, die habe ich gleich mal bestellt.
In English and Spanish.
Die kosten noch die Hälfte. Als die abgekündigt wurden.
Die sind zwischen den Kleinen ganz gut, weil der 10er Block, der ist einfach nur so unseh, Kronen in der Mitte.
Ich hasse diese FN-Taste da. Die ist bei der Kleinen ja da auch.
Das geht aber. Habe ich die eigentlich?
Die große?
Also ich habe noch drei original eingepackte.
Echt?
In English International oder Deutsch? Deutsch.
Kannst du mir da mal eine mitbringen?
Wie eine mitbringen?
Das kostet.
Das kostet. Drei Jahre alt.
Ja, ehrlich? Ja, ich muss mal nummern, Pat, mal, vielleicht kann ich damit besser...
Buch halten.
Buchen. Also mit Macs ist es wie mit Babyzügehör. Da kann man noch Geld mit verdienen beim Kauf.
Naja, gut. Wir besuchen dich dann.
Falls ihr gerade Kinder kriegt, kleiner Tipp, ja, so von Eltern zu Eltern. Kauft immer den teuersten, angesagtesten Scheiß, den es gibt. Ja, so Zustellbettchen und so weiter. Nicht das Sonderangebot von Babywalz nehmen. Nein, kauft das rechts unten Modell, was richtig scheiße teuer ist, in der besten Ausführung.
Das geht damit ordentlich um?
Ja, ich meine, da liegt drei Monate lang irgendwie ein Baby drin, das ist festgeschraubt, da geht halt nicht viel kaputt.
Das Baby ist festgeschraubt, genau.
Das wird einfach mitgeliefert.
Nee, aber es ist genau dasselbe Ding irgendwie. Du kaufst es irgendwie zum neuen Preis.
Keiner kauft es gebraucht, nur das gute Zeug wollen sie halt für ein bisschen billiger.
Genau, mit dem besonderen Effekt ist halt auf Ebay, ist halt alles immer ein bisschen so, also in diesem Babybereich ist es ein bisschen fies, aber das ist die Realität. Es ist halt alles voll mit so hormonell etwas übersteuerten werdenden Müttern, die halt immer so das beste Kind haben wollen. Und die wollen dann halt das tolle Babybay haben. Und das muss es dann halt sein, weil das so schön ist. Und unser Baby war immer glücklich und hat gut darin geschlafen und so. Und dann überbieten die sich irgendwie über den Neupreis und man macht da halt sogar noch einen Mark.
Über den Neupreis?
Ja.
Habt ihr das so gemacht?
Also nicht absichtlich, das war einfach der Effekt. Das hab ich einfach beobachtet. Ich konnte ja nichts dafür. Also die haben ja einfach so gewohnt.
Weil das so gut lief, hat Tim dann einfach gedacht, so noch ein Kind.
Stimmt, weil mit Kindern macht man nämlich echt plus.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so.
Eine Wertanlage.
Ist jetzt aber nicht so, dass du auch deine iPads in Rosa kaufst für die werdenden Mütter hinterher.
Nein, nein. Ich sag nur, es lohnt sich einfach, also in diesem Segment, wo doch ordentliche Preise aufgerufen werden, ist einfach der Werterhalt so enorm, dass er am Ende eigentlich dazu führt, dass man eigentlich nichts dafür bezahlt. Und ich meine, mal ehrlich, ihr kennt doch diesen Effekt auch nicht. Das ist immer dieses, ach ja, unsere Windows-Rechner, die waren ja so billig. Nur was man dann halt einfach aufwenden muss, einerseits um die Dinge überhaupt in Betrieb zu halten, aber andererseits, was man dann eben nicht dafür bekommt, wenn man die dann wieder verkauft, das rechnet sich halt einfach nicht, find's zu teuer. So, Amen. Hier meint eine Abschreibung in drei Jahren, das werden wir neu, hängt von der Höhe des Einkaufspreises ab, nein, das hängt nicht von der Höhe des Einkaufspreises ab, das hängt davon ab, was es ist.
Wir besuchen dich dann im Uli Hoeneß Gedächtnis Steuerknast. Wollen sie dich dann auch rauslassen, damit du mit uns die Freak Show aufnehmen kannst? Also das wär ja nochmal interessant, ob sie dich dann rauslassen.
Ich bau das Gefängnis um. Ach, ich sende einfach direkt aus dem Knast. Was, wieso, seid ihr schon durch oder was?
23 Sekunden.
Du hast Erfahrungsberichte, die wollen wir hören.
Noch zum Thema Geldanlage. Man kann derzeit, wenn man die richtigen Autos kauft, die tatsächlich hinterher auch für mehr Geld verkaufen. Ich hab's jetzt nicht nur ohne Schaden. Nee, ich hab's für die Zoys verfolgt. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass so eine Zoe mit jetzt nicht allzu vielen Kilometern konntest du irgendwie, sagen wir mal, Ende letzten Jahres noch für 10K kriegen. Also das ganz alte Modell, drei Jahre alt. Und jetzt bist du schon so bei 14 oder so. Das ist völlig absurd. Die sind teurer geworden.
Ja, Angebot in Nachfrage. Ich glaub, mit unserem Tesla, wenn du die jetzt so neu einkaufst und den...
Wenn du guckst, wenn du guckst, wenn du ein Tesla Model S für 35.000 gebraucht haben willst, kriegst du nichts unter 300.000 Kilometer. Das ist völlig absurd.
Das sind die ganzen Leasing-Geschosser wahrscheinlich.
Woher denkst du, ein Auto mit 300.000 Kilometern, dass überhaupt noch jemand freiwillig vom Schrottplatz fährt? Nee, da werden richtig Preise aufgerufen. Das ist total der Hammer.
Da ist halt kein Motor drin, der sich rotten konnte.
Es geht halt nichts groß dran kaputt. Neue Reifen, ein paar Stoßdämpfer, fertig.
Na gut, aber jetzt... das nur so am Rande.
Ja, aber das ist eigentlich ein ähnliches... Das ist halt generell diese Sache mit... wertige Dinge lohnen sich.
Ja, es ist natürlich auch so, dass die Hersteller halt einfach nicht liefern können oder wollen. Also, ich meine, VW hat jetzt dieses Jahresproduktionen eGolf quasi verkauft und haben angekündigt, wird nicht weiter verkauft. Und wenn du jetzt keinen bestellt hast, dann kriegst du den neu halt nicht mehr. Ist Feierabend mit eGolf.
Es gibt kein eGolf mehr?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, die Bestellungsliste ist zu. Die haben die Jahresproduktion quasi abverkauft.
Und wollen sie sie auch wieder öffnen?
Nee, ich nehme mal an, dass sie diesen ID, den sie da schon seit einer Weile ankündigen, dann anstatt des eGolf verkaufen. Es gibt da nur noch diesen Fake Hybrid, diesen mit 48 Volt Motoren, diesen etwas besseren Anlass, den sie da anbauen an den Motor.
Wo wir gerade bei dem E-Auto-Thema sind, kannst du noch mal kurz das Update zu deiner Saga machen? Du hast jetzt ein neues.
Ich habe jetzt eine neue Zoe in Schwarz, oder Pearl Black, wie die Farbe heißt.
Also extra heiß im Sommer.
Es geht, hat eine Klimaanlage. Die verbraucht doch gar nicht so viel Strom.
Das ist auch so geil. Schwarzes Auto, schön die Hitze einsaugen und dann irgendwie mit der Klimaanlage so richtig die Akkus tosten.
Nö, die verbraucht nicht so viel. Also die Heizung verbraucht mehr als die Klimaanlage. Ja, weil die Heizung und die Klimaanlage ist doch dasselbe oder nicht? Im Prinzip ja, aber der Temperatur, also das Temperaturgefälle im Winter ist halt größer als im Sommer. Also zumindest jetzt noch. Ich weiß nicht, wenn es jetzt draußen 37 Grad hat, können wir nochmal reden.
Ja, aber dann willst du 10 Grad runterkühlen, dann ist das schon erfrischend. Im Winter sind minus 20 Grad draußen. Da willst du dann auch trotzdem 15. Na, wir hatten ja schon minus 16 in der Stadt.
Ja, deswegen musst du da halt nochmal...
Da musst du ja so 30 Grad plus...
Mit einem Widerstandselement zuheizen und das kostet halt richtig Strom.
Egal.
Weil, was war die Frage?
Ja, einfach was ist der Start? Du hast das Ding und...
Wie lange hast du es denn schon?
Seit vorletzter Woche Donnerstag. Also den Tag nach der letzten Sendung wurde das Teil quasi in drei Linden vor dem Büro abgeliefert, wo ich dann noch getweetet habe, dass ich in Sachen Dinge ins Büro liefern mal... Sollen Maßstab gesetzt hab, genau.
Also hast du jetzt sozusagen 0,01 Cappuccinos. Lange. Oder so in etwa. In wie vielen Tagen hattest du den?
Welche Farbe hat deine Kiste vorher?
Braun.
Braun Metallic.
Das heißt eigentlich ist jetzt alles schick. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ich fand das Braun eigentlich gar nicht so. Ich fand die Farbe eigentlich ganz cool. Abgesehen davon, dass Renault natürlich weiß eine Elektro-Auto ist. So komische blaue Farbakzente bei den Lichtern vorne und hinten setzen muss und die beißen sich natürlich ein bisschen mit dem Braun. Aber ansonsten.
Der Schwarze hat das jetzt auch.
Der hat das jetzt auch und da stört es nicht weiter, weil schwarz und blau sich jetzt nicht so beißen farblich. Der hat jetzt den großen Akku. Das heißt, das habe ich schon letztes Mal 300 Kilometer kommen halt so raus jetzt bei dem Wetter. Das ist schon ganz okay. Ansonsten ja, also das einzige, was mich wirklich nervt, ist aber das ist mehr so dieses dieses Renault Media System, was sie da eingebaut haben. Also da gibt es einen USB Port und da kann man dann sein Handy anschließen und dann kann man quasi über die USB-Schnittstelle hat man den Sound in einem Auto. Klingt auch okay. Einziger Pferdefuß. Das Ding lädt das Telefon nicht aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Das ist irgendwie ein bekannter Fehler. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich so ein Zigarettenanzünder zu USB-Power-Adapter-Ding sie da nehmen und das Telefon mit Bluetooth verbinden, aber irgendwie schafft er es nicht, irgendeins von diesen Profilen auszusuchen, dass es auch nach was klingt. Das heißt, man hat entweder guten Sound oder Power auf dem Telefon, aber beides zusammen geht nicht. Weil du denkst, wie weit habt ihr jetzt da mitgedacht? Man merkt, es ist halt ein Renault. Also das ist irgendwie so... Aber im Prinzip erfährt gut. Also ich will mich nicht beschweren.
So Hockerich, mich würde ja mal deine Erfahrung mit dem L-12 interessieren.
Ja, nachdem ich Tim mich hier in der Sendung oder vor der Sendung irgendwann mal angefixt hatte mit diesem L-12 und Tim sich dann gleich zur nächsten Sendung schon hier auf den Tisch gestellt hatte...
What the fuck ist L-12?
Der Zoom L-12, ein 12-Kanal-Audio-Mixer-Recorder- USB-Audio-Interface mit 5 Kopfhörer-Ausgängen.
Die separat mixbar sind.
Der neue heiße Scheiß für den Podcaster und auch zu Hause im Heim.
Oder den Musiker.
Das waren das erste Teil, was gleichzeitig auf SD-Karte aufnehmen kann und Multitrack-Interface sein kann für den Computer.
Also so ein All-in-one-Hardware.
Genau, so ein All-in-one-Digitalmixer mit ordentlichen Kompromissen und für einen korrekten Preis.
Ein korrekter Preis ist 599, glaube ich.
Wie groß ist das Ding physikalisch so? Also schon ordentlich Hardware. Wir sind gar nicht so viel unterwegs. Habt ihr nicht gerade unterwegs gesagt?
19 Zoll heißt ja breit, aber der ist relativ kurz und nicht hoch.
Ja, das ist auch leicht. Das ist schon ein Pflasterbomber. Dann hatte Tim den hier stehen. Dann wurde ich auch schon gleich ein bisschen unruhig.
Wie der Fingerjuppen bestellen.
Ich habe den ja schon vor Tim auf der Wunschliste gehabt. Ich habe ja dann Tim davon erzählen. Dann hat Tim den gleich bestellt. Das Ding gar nicht, ne? Ich hatte das für einen Proberaum gedacht. Im Proberaum haben wir eine PA, wo die Sängerin drüber singt, um sich selber zu hören. Und wir alle, die dann hören. Deswegen brauchen wir auch einen Live-Mixer, wo ihr Mikro reingeht und das an die PA geht. Gleichzeitig will ich auch Demo-Aufnahmen im Proberaum machen. Ich würde dann Mikros ans Schlagzeug, an die Gitarrenverstärker, Bassverstärker etc. anschließen. Die müssen aber nicht über die PA raus. Das heißt, ein flexibles Mixing, was aufgenommen wird und was über die PA geht. Und die Möglichkeit, wenn man Demos aufnimmt, dass die Leute sich Kopfhörer aufsetzen und man dem Schlagzeuger vor allem Bass und Vocals gibt. Und den Gitarren vielleicht mehr Schlagzeug und so auf die Kopfhörer mixes. Dann habe ich mir den zusammen mit unserem Schlagzeuger bestellt. Wir haben ihn dann zusammengelegt. Und dann bei Erdgeiss Geburtstag war fast... Ich habe es vorher zwar mal im Proberaum schon probiert und damit auch acht Spuren direkt voll aufgenommen mit Mikros und allem. Und es hat sich extrem gut gemacht. Und dann habe ich es auch nochmal bei Erdgeiss Geburtstagsparty benutzt, um die andere Band aufzunehmen. Denn bei unserer eigenen Band habe ich vergessen, in der ganzen Aufregung auf Record zu drücken. Sehr schade. Aber es gibt andere gute Aufnahmen, die gibt es bald in Kürze. So und jetzt im Prinzip würde ich sogar sagen, alles das, was so prinzipiell das Gerät verspricht, so von den Features her, erfüllt es auch zur vollkommenen Zufriedenstellung. Also ich hatte jetzt echt nichts, wo ich sagen würde, ah ne, das ist aber doch blöd. Was mir so an der Verarbeitung aufgefallen ist, dass halt so diese Potis oder die Knöpfchen so an manchen Sachen so ein bisschen sehr lose oder wackelig sind und sich jetzt nicht so schön wertig, leicht schwergängig anfühlen, sondern halt so flimsi. Das ist ein bisschen schade. Und was halt auch mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, beim Podcast aufzunehmen mit dem, wie heißt das, DT-297-DT?
DT-297-PV-R80.
Hatte ich bei mir zu Hause das Problem, dass die Netzbrummen verursacht haben in den Spuren. Und das ist natürlich irgendwie eher uncool gewesen. Und ich hab jetzt schon viel rumprobiert, ob das an den Headsets liegt oder nicht. Und im Internet steht ja ja prinzipiell, alles, was so ein Vorverstärker hat, kriegt halt so Netzbrummen irgendwie mit rein. Manche mehr, manche weniger. Es gibt ja hier für dieses legendäre Superlux-Headset-Thema von Ralf, wo sich ja auch Leute über so Netzbrummen beschweren, so diese Erdungskabel, die sie sich dann löten und an irgendwelche Buchsen mit dranstecken, um irgendwie das Brummen wegzukriegen. Habe ich jetzt alles nicht gemacht, aber bei normalen Mikros, also Kondensator, Großmembran, XLR mit Phantomspeisung hatte ich kein Netzbrummen, nur bei den Headsets halt bisher. Und ich kann mir das jetzt noch nicht so genau erklären. Die Kabel neben Beyerdynamik, Adapter Schnupsi, die waren alle richtig belegt. Das tritt auch stärker, auch wenn man ein bisschen Kompressor mit rein regelt. Also wenn man den Kompressor ganz raus lässt, dann erkennt auch Phonik das nicht. Aber es ist da. Ich habe den Kopfhörerverstärker dann mal voll aufgedreht. Also Gain auf dem Eingangskanal nicht so hoch. Aber dann den Kopfhörer halt mal voll rauf, um zu gucken, ob es da ist und es ist da. Und wie gesagt, bei den anderen Mikros, die ich so habe, die jetzt nicht im Headset eingebaut sind, habe ich diesen Effekt nicht hörbar und auch von Euphonik nicht dediktiert bisher gehabt. Was mir halt so ein bisschen Rätsel aufgibt und ich nicht ganz genau verstehe, was dann jetzt bei den Headset so groß anders sein soll, ob jetzt hier intern irgendwie die Isolierung nicht so geil ist und bei mir in der Wohnung vielleicht elektromagnetisch sowieso noch ein bisschen mehr Party abgeht oder keine Ahnung. Unklar. Das wäre jetzt nur so eine Beobachtung gewesen.
Hast du denn Erkenntnisse, an welcher Stelle das Brummen entsteht? Also ist das Brummen auch schon in den Aufnahmen? Also ist das quasi...
Jaja, also auf Phonic detectet das ja in den Tracks und filtert das dann raus. Und ich hatte ja einen Podcast aufgenommen, wo ich deine zwei Headsets, die ich mir geliehen hatte, und ich habe selber aber ein großes Vembran-Kondensatum vor die Schnute gehalten mit einem extra Kopfhörer, wie ich ja sonst immer so aufnehme, weil ich ja keine Headsets habe eigentlich.
Vielleicht hast du einfach ein Montagsgerät. Ich habe ja auch die Headsets da dran gehabt bei mir und ich hatte den Effekt nicht, vielleicht sollten wir nach der Sendung nochmal kurz testen.
Genau, oder ich habe auch bei mir zu Hause sowieso mit... Ich glaube, mein Strom ist nicht so der sauberste.
Ich kann sagen, vielleicht hast du den falschen Strom.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich kann nur nochmal wiederholen, die anderen Mikros haben das halt nicht auf ihren Spuren gehabt. Und ich habe jetzt schon mal alle so, die ich so habe mal durchgetestet, von Bändchen-Mikrofon zu Großmembran, mit Phantomspeisung, von dynamischen Mikrofonen und keiner hat dieses Netzbrumm drauf, nur bei den Headsets. Und ich frage mich halt, ob das so durch Kopfhörer und Mikrofon, sozusagen getrennt eingestöpselt, ob da irgendwas nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, aber ich bin da auch. Eine Einschränkung kann ich noch dazu sagen, weil bei dem L-12 die Kopfhörerausgänge relativ weit von den XLR-Eingängen sind, musste ich halt mal ein Kabel verlängern, entweder das XLR-Kabel oder das Kopfhörerkabel. Kann es daher kommen?
Ja, je nachdem wie die Verlängerung gelötet ist schon.
Das waren auch gute Kabel.
Hast du es mal probiert, nur das Mikrofon einzustecken, ohne den Kopfhörer eingesteckt zu haben? Ob es dann auch brummt? Das wäre das nächste, was ich probieren würde.
Das können wir natürlich auch nochmal testen. Aber jetzt habe ich die Headset ja dem Tim wiedergebracht, das muss er dann mal testen. Ich wollte das nochmal gesagt haben.
Ein Trick ist, große Batterie, die benutzen und nicht die Steckdose, und für den Verstärker irgendwie optisch das Signal übermitteln und dann kann der das mit Strom verstärken und rausballern, aber dass dein ganzes Normal-Strom-Set gar nicht an der Steckdose dranhängt. Ich weiß, hört sich jetzt ein bisschen zu easy an, so mach doch ohne Strom. Aber auch, wenn ich mit einem Scope-Meter oder Elektro-Equipment teste und ich da meine 50 Hertz störend rein kriege, dann ziehe ich halt das Ladekabel raus, das Ding hat ja eine Batterie, und dann läuft das halt ohne Strom von der Batterie und dann hast du auch plötzlich keinen 50-Hertz-Brummen mehr.
Das Ding hat keine Batterie.
Deswegen sag ich ja Autobatterie oder du machst ja deinen eigenen Strom da irgendwie.
Ich wollte auch nur das erwähnt haben, das müssen wir jetzt halt vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen evaluieren, weil ich hab tatsächlich zuhause schon auch so ein bisschen Noisy-Strom-Situation ab und zu, die ich weitestgehend, also zum Beispiel in Audio und Flat, ich hatte das eigentlich noch nie in Spuren, also in 50 Hz auf Phonik, das ich detektiert hab. Das ist wirklich das erste Mal und vor allen Dingen nur mit den Headsets gewesen. So, das nur dazu gesagt.
Ja, aber das muss nicht am Strom liegen. Das ist vielleicht auch Brummeinstrahlung von irgendwo, irgendein fieses Netzteil, der Amp, der da rumsteht oder so, wo das Kabel dran vorbeigeht, sowas kann es nämlich auch sein.
Ich wollte nur gesagt haben, dass man das vielleicht nochmal testet, für Leute, die das auch schon geklickt haben. Wenn das nur bei mir ist, ist das auch okay. Ansonsten... Auf Phonik filtert es ja auch raus, das ist kein Problem.
Aber besser wäre es, wenn es Kabelcher Stars.
Will man nicht haben, sowas. Ansonsten bin ich total happy damit. Ich finde auch so das User-Interface, Sie haben ja nur einen Channel-Strip, also Equalizer. Jeder Eingangskanal auf so einem großen Mischputt hat noch 1000 Knöpfe nach oben und das sind dann so Equalizer und irgendwelche Filter oder so. Dieses Ding hat einen so einen Channel-Strip, so heißt das dann. Du kannst dir halt aussuchen, für welchen Kanal der gerade gilt. Du kannst dann sagen, hier Kanal 1.
Und das also dynamisch belegen.
Genau, und auch so diese Szenen abspeichern, also dass man im Prinzip das Ding hat, auch keine Motor-Fader wie Tims großes Mischputt hier. Aber es hat LEDs neben den Fadern. Und wenn du zwischen so den verschiedenen Kanälen wechselst oder verschiedenen Mixen für die Kopfhörer, dann zeigt dir mit den LEDs an, wo die Fader waren. Und dann kannst du es ändern. Und das funktioniert in der Praxis auch ziemlich gut. Also ich habe mich echt relativ schnell mit dem Gerät so zurechtgefunden, dass ich so bei dieser Aufnahme mit 8 Spuren oder auch in dieser Live-Situation da zurande gekommen bin, was mich sehr positiv gestimmt hat. Weil ich fand so bei Zoom auch manchmal bei diesen kleinen Rekordern so die Menüführung furchtbar. Da kommt man echt schnell zu Ergebnissen, ohne zu tief überhaupt in irgendwelche Menüs da eintauchen zu müssen. Und das Menu ist auch wirklich relativ übersichtlich geil. Also ich war echt positiv überrascht eigentlich.
Benutzt du den mit dem Treiber oder benutzt...
Ich habe noch nicht am Computer angeschlossen.
Ich mache ja eigentlich mobile meine Aufnahmen mit dem Zoom H6 und ich habe jetzt seit ein paar Wochen aus dem Nichts heraus wieder USB Fehler. Das Audio kommt halt zerstört an.
Mit welchem Gerät nochmal, sorry?
Mit dem H6. Das lief jetzt zwei Jahre lang, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange ich das jetzt schon einsetze, also ewig problemlos und ich weiß nicht, ob das durch irgendein OS Update, irgendein 10.3, 10.4, irgendwas Update getriggert wurde. Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt wieder geknackse und gewürge und hab schnauze voll. Dieses USB wird einfach nicht besser. Deswegen ist es für mich jetzt entscheidend, dieses Backup zu haben. Und jetzt muss ich mir halt eine schöne Transportkombination ausdenken. Ich habe, glaube ich, schon eine gefunden. Mal gucken, wie ich das jetzt so mache. Aber ich glaube, der L-12 wird es jetzt erstmal werden. Es sei denn, ich habe jetzt auch diese Brummprobleme.
Aber teste das auf jeden Fall mal. Das würde mich dann auch nochmal sehr interessieren. Und was übrigens wirklich auch sehr cool funktioniert, sind so für unterschiedliche Kopfhörerausgänge, die unterschiedliche Mixe machen. Weil bei Band ist das halt wirklich ein Thema, bei Podcast wahrscheinlich eher weniger. Aber da war es wirklich so, der Drummer wollte was komplett anderes laut haben als die Sängerin und die Gitarren.
Der Klassiker.
Nicht so in dieser Feinabstimmung, aber so für so N-1-Situationen oder gerade wenn man jetzt so ein Bühnen-Setup macht. Also ich bin ja zum Beispiel übermorgen mit Linus auf der GPN. Und dann machen wir irgendwie kurz so ein bisschen ohne große Show einfach nur eine Sendung live. So und dann werde ich dann auch den L-12 nehmen, um sozusagen uns schon mal lokal auf der Bühne zu recorden, Multitrack und dann halt ein Signal zu liefern. Und wenn man dann aber eben so was, wenn man sich jetzt so ein Setup noch vorstellt mit, äh, was weiß ich hier, ähm, Zuschauer-Mikrofon oder Atmo-Mikro, was du auch noch mit aufnehmen willst oder irgendjemand soll das abhören oder so. Also du wirst immer wieder irgendwelche Setups haben, wo du dann eben verschiedene Mixe gebrauchen kannst. Und es ist schon mal sehr gut zu wissen, dass du in diesem einen Paket eben bis zu fünf schon mal machen kannst. Und das deckt schon mal viele Sonderfälle wunderbar ab. Und vor allem du kannst halt einfach aufnehmen. Nichts geht verloren.
Wie gesagt, ich kann es auch nur sagen, für den Preis und das, was sie so auf die Packung schreiben, ist eigentlich alles auch erfüllt. Das Einzige ist wirklich so... Diese Knöpfchen, die könnten noch ein bisschen geiler sein. Gerade der Kompressorknopf, der ist irgendwie sehr lose, zumindest jetzt bei meinem Gerät. Und ich finde jetzt auch den Kompressor nicht besonders geil. Also den kann man sparsam mit reinregeln, aber wenn man den so ein bisschen so Richtung 12 Uhr dreht, dann gefällt es dir nicht, mag es dir nicht.
Du meinst noch mal eine Generation abwarten?
Ja, ich meine, mit ein bisschen Kompressor reicht dann auch. Das klingt dann auch okay und ich habe einfach das Gefühl, der ist dann sehr empfindlich, wenn du den ein bisschen lauter drehst, keine Ahnung, dann klingt das einfach nicht gut.
Der hat aber keine Motorfader, ne?
Genau, das meinte ich ja gerade. Du hast eben diese LEDs, die dir dann zeigen, in welcher Szene oder in welchem Mix, wo die Fader da gerade waren. Dann musst du mit dem Fader, wenn er nicht an dieser Position ist, einmal zu der LED fahren und dann kannst du es ändern. Aber es geht wirklich ziemlich gut. Das ist ein guter Kompromiss für... Weil, wenn du jetzt noch zwölf Motorfader hast, dann wäre das Gerät mindestens doppelt so teuer, wahrscheinlich.
Und größer und schwerer.
Oh, das wären scheiß Motorfader. Genau. Also insofern... Ich bin glücklich. Die Bandaufnahmen hatten auch kein Brummen. Ich muss... Ich hau gleich noch schnell einen hinterher. Oder beide. Ich hab ja seit eh und je, und nicht seit eh und je, aber schon seit acht Jahren oder so meinen eigenen Mailserver am Start. Und hatte da so ein etwas elaboriertes Mailserver, und ich hab irgendwie in meinen Anfangszeit beim Club irgendwie auch bei jedem irgendwie auf einem Mailserver-Account noch so mir eingesammelt und hat zig Mail-Accounts, die hab ich dann alle durch Weiterleitung irgendwie versucht, den einzukanalisieren. Aber ich war eigentlich über meine Hauptdomänen für meine Mail, also hier Smick Org, war ich eigentlich gar nicht der Chef im Haus, sondern es lief noch so über Erdgeist Mailserver und DNS-Server und ich dachte mir boah, jetzt kommt da so viel Spam und ich kann den nicht ablehnen, weil sonst ballere ich seinen Mailserver mit den rejecteten Mails wieder voll dachte mir, ok, ich muss da jetzt mal ran. Ich will Spam ordentlich filtern und ich will die DMX-Domänen auch auf meinen Server zeigen lassen und nicht noch diesen Umweg nehmen. Dann habe ich erstmal schon vor kurzem einen Post gesehen über einen neuen Spam-Filter. Ich habe seit eh und je Spam-Assassin mit Amavis-D und so diese Perl-Grutze, die man eigentlich überhaupt nicht benutzen will und die auch nicht gut gefiltert hat, muss man sagen, ersetzen und da habe ich dieses Rspam-D gefunden.
Wofür steht das R eigentlich?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie... Also es ist von einem Menschen mit slawischem Namen oder auf jeden Fall aus dem östlichen Teil des eurasischen Kontinents erstellt und der ist auf FreeBSD-Committer oder zumindest engagiert in FreeBSD und es ist auch in C geschrieben und es hat so diesen, also die Software hat schon auch so ein sehr bare-metal-Appeal, so keinen Schnickschnack, kein noch Node.js-Web-Server für das Web-Interface, sondern es ist einfach ein Stück HTML mit ein bisschen JavaScript drin. Das kannst du mit irgendeinem pupigen Engine X oder was auch immer ausliefern. Und der verbindet sich dann mit Websocket zu dem Spam-D mit Passwort natürlich und so. Und vor allen Dingen, was er für mich getan hat, nicht nur hat er dieses Amavist-D, das Spam-Assassin, das Open-DKIM ersetzt. Ja, also ich hab jetzt drei Tools für eins getauscht. Und vor allen Dingen ganz viel Perl-Grütze gegen ein Stück so schrumpige C-Software. Und der Bill bietet halt extrem viele coole Features. Also wie gesagt, DKIM macht da eh gleich schon mit drin.
Das DKIM ist das, was jetzt auch das Open-SPF eigentlich schon mit drin hat, oder? War das das, was so beides benutzt?
Also erstens performt er richtig geil, zweitens hat er viele Features. Der baut halt Greylisting mit ein. Der hat sozusagen, naja, es steht jetzt auf der Webseite, ein neuronales Netzwerk. Wenn man so richtig viel Spam von vielen Usern hat, dann werden halt Spamfilter ja auch unscharf. Weil was für den einen Spam ist, ist vielleicht für den anderen Hemm. Und genau, also er hat irgendwie im Prinzip alles drin und noch viel mehr, was man so haben wollen würde als Spamfilter, inklusive einem Webinterface, wo man eben ganz bequem auch Falls-Positives für Hemm oder Spam nachlernen kann. Man sieht auch eine Liste schön in dem Webinterface von der Mail, die gefiltert wurde und warum und welche Checks da angeschlagen haben und welcher Score. Also es ist super transparent, was da so passiert. Das ist super easy zu konfigurieren und in seinen Postfix in meinem Fall mit reinzukleben. Dieses Mail-Signieren, also dieses DKIM, war auch super easy aufzusetzen. Musste da eigentlich fast kaum Doku lesen. Es gibt so ein Tutorial tatsächlich auch für FreeBSD mit Postfix, was jetzt genau meinen Fall glücklicherweise abgedeckelt hat. Aber es gab auch noch ein anderes Tutorial da mit Linux drin. Und wer jetzt noch selber einen Mail-Server hat und immer noch Spam-Assassin benutzt, Leute, wirklich tut euch was Gutes. Schmeißt den Spam-Assassin weg und installiert Rspam. Ich habe seitdem fast keinen Spam. Also wirklich einmal die Woche kommt vielleicht noch irgendeine Mail durch, die nicht durchkommen sollte, und die Falls Positives. Also fairerweise alles, was im Spam-Orner landet, was ich vorher vielleicht noch nicht als Spam deklariert hätte, ist am Ende Werbung. Es sind alles so Newsletter mit irgendwie, hey, wir haben hier eine neue Version, willst du nicht nochmal upgraden und so. Also es ist technisch gesehen Spam-Werbe-Mail, die jetzt halt aber auch wirklich als solche erkannt wird. Und ich mache es jetzt gerade so, ich bin immer noch in der Beobachtungsphase, dass ich halt so jeden Tag oder am Abend dann so in den Spam-Folder gucke, einmal so, was ist da drin? Ja, alles klar.
Kannst du die dann da rausziehen in so ein Hem-Ordner und dann lernt er das dann gleich wieder neu?
Nein, es gibt einmal die Möglichkeit im Web-Interface, kannst du die halt einfach den Raw-Mail-Source reinpasten und sagen, Learn Hem, Learn Spam. Oder du kannst halt, der kommt dann halt mit zwei so Special-Mail-Adressen an, die du die Mails einfach forwarden kannst.
Man kann ja sowas über iMap-Folder machen.
Das kannst du auch, aber das war jetzt nicht so, zumindest wenn ich mich recht ins Sinne war, es nicht so super easy aufzusetzen. Also nicht so, ich schmeiße das jetzt mal eben hin und bin in einer halben Stunde fertig, sondern da musste man dann mit DoveCut irgendwie noch, mit dem iMap-D noch ein bisschen...
Ja, also jetzt vom User-AP her würde ich sagen, wäre das ja das Einfasse, du hast halt irgendwas, was im Spam, was da nicht rein soll. Du schmeißt das in einen Hem-Ordner, der nimmt sich das wieder raus, trainiert das um und tut es wieder in die Inbox.
Ja, für meinen Fall... Also erstens habe ich extrem wenig Falls-Positives und zweitens fand ich auch das charmant genug, einfach an diese Hem-Mail-Adresse das zu forwarden und fertig. Also ist jetzt auch nicht viel langsamer, als die Mail da in die Ornner zu ziehen. Wie gesagt, kann man ja auch so einrichten, dann musst du aber eben deinen IMAP-D entsprechend noch mit so einem Thief-Script versehen, wahrscheinlich. Genau, aber dieses Web-Interface, wie gesagt, das ist halt im Prinzip ein statisches HTML mit ein bisschen JavaScript, finde ich extrem gut gelungen. Also für so einen FreeBSD-C-Coder hätte man das jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt erwarten können, ohne den Herrschaften zu nahe zu treten zu wollen.
Die werden auch besser.
Die werden auch besser, ich kann ja euch da nachher... Vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwo ein Demo-Interface, aber ich finde das auf jeden Fall ziemlich cool.
Und macht der dann so richtig Machine Learning oder was?
Sagen sie ja.
Das finde ich ja ganz feist, weil ich denke mal, das dürfte eigentlich bei Spam sehr gut anschlagen.
Also wie gesagt, die machen eigentlich alles, was so State of the Art ist. Du hast auch, du kannst, also er macht interne Fishing-Checks nach so ein paar Regeln, wie zum Beispiel sind da so Shortcut-URLs drin und so weiter, aber du kannst den auch mit so OpenFish oder Fishtank-Databases verbinden und eben dann auch den, wenn halt 50 Leute eine Mail als Fishing da schon qualifiziert haben, dann kannst du das da auch mit abernten. Das Graylisting finde ich extrem schön. Also es funktioniert wirklich sehr gut, sehr gut eingetunt, schon von Hause aus, also da muss sich gar nichts dran drehen.
Also Graylisting für die, die jetzt nicht wissen, wovon Huckel redet, ist so dieses, ich nehme die Mail nicht sofort an, sondern verzögere.
Ich rejakte die sogar erstmal und dann gute Mail-Server senden die halt nochmal.
Ja, aber rejekten mit so einem Flag, ich kann grad nicht, weil das Teil des Mail-Protokolls ist. Und nach dem Motto, komm mal später wieder.
Ich bin grad besie.
Einer, der Millionen von Mails rausballert, der hat keine Datenbank, um sich zu merken, wo er jetzt nochmal senden muss, weil das ist einfach egal. Die verzichten dann einfach und kommen nicht mehr wieder und schon hast du den Spam.
Ah ja, hier guck mal, das Web-Interface, ist das Clickband oder sind das nur Screenshots?
Aber immerhin.
Ja, ich kann euch das hier dann nochmal auf meinem Screen zeigen. Das sieht wirklich echt ganz cool aus. Also auch die Graphen, was gerade so los ist und so. Ach hier, nee im Moment, gibt's da nicht noch irgendwie so zum Klicken Demo?
Demo sehe ich hier gerade nicht.
Wie voll kann vielleicht... Ja, okay, wenn ihr das sehen wollt, könnt ihr mal bei mir dann nochmal klicken. Ja, und auch so dieses SPF und DKIM-Checking. Also man kann das echt sehr schick einstellen. Und...
SPF hatte auch mit dabei, warst du vorhin nicht erwähnt?
Naja, also wie gesagt, alles was so State-of-the-Art-Spam-Filtering ist, dafür gibt's da Rules oder Engines sozusagen. Und natürlich auch SPF, wo du sagen kannst, was dann da deine Policy sein soll. Ich hab auch jetzt meinen Mail-Server, also meine SPF- und DKIM-Records relativ streng eingestellt.
Nur von hier und sonst nirgends, bang!
Und dann schmeißt gleich in Quarantäne und so weiter. Ja, und das ist ganz geil. Und wenn du diesen DMARC-Record noch setzt, für deine Domain, dann kriegst du ja von den großen Mail-Providern so ein Report.
Du kriegst sogar einen Hinweis, wenn jemand versucht hat, von einem anderen Domain irgendwie Mail zu senden. Da kannst du erstens deinen eigenen Fehler mit fixen und zweitens sehen, ob jemand versucht dich da zu verarschen von irgendwo.
Das ist echt auch sehr cool, weil das hat dich vorher auch noch nicht eingestellt und das ist ein ganz cooles Feedback. Und dann gibt es eben noch so ein, zwei Services, um die Mail, also die eigenen Settings, uns so mal zu testen. Das eine ist ja dieses mailtester.com. Pack ich noch mal in den Chat, das hatte ich bestimmt schon ein paar Mal erwähnt. Da kann man einfach mal eine Mail hinschicken und gucken, wie so der eigene Mail-Server so performt in Sachen SPF Records, DKIM, Signatur, ob hier irgendwie alle Header korrekt gesetzt sind, etc., pp. Und dann, oh Gott, wie ist das andere? Puh, muss ich gleich noch mal raus, wenn ich fertig bin mit labern, dann schreibe ich noch so einen Link rein, da gab es nicht so einen Service, da muss man, glaube ich, so 5 Dollar mal mit Paypal rüber schicken, aber die machen wirklich einen so bis in den hinterletzten Winkel von allem, was du so einstellen kannst, inklusive SSL oder TLS-Konfigurationen und hast du wirklich jetzt auch deine SPF Records korrekt formatiert und wirklich also so einen Irrsinn an Detail, aber auch da war dann bei mir am Ende alles grün. Deswegen Happy Happy Joy Joy. Und um diese Records zu setzen, meine Domain war halt auch immer noch bei Erdgeist gehostet auf seinem Nameserver und der benutzt so einen Tiny DNS hier von DJB mit irgendwelchen Custom Patches für IPv6 und ich krieg da jedes Mal den Ultra-Brechreiz, wenn ich dann irgendeinen Convert davon, so sieht eine IP-Adresse und so will Tiny DNS die IP-Adresse formatiert haben oder Text-Records, das ist einfach wie man diese Software überhaupt noch benutzen kann, eine Brezel für mich. Deswegen dachte ich mir, okay, ich muss da weg. Ich hol jetzt meine eigene Domain und der Clemens hat sich netterweise bereit erklärt mir die Secondary DNS Server sozusagen.
Das Backup DNS zu machen sozusagen.
Das Backup DNS zu machen und dann habe ich mal an einem Nachmittag meine Domains quasi umgezogen auf meinen Name Server mit Backup auf Clemens Name Server und habe jetzt volle Kontrolle über Mail und Domain und fühle mich Empowert. Ja, es ist wieder, also bei der Uni hat man ja auch mal so diese Spielwiese mit den UDK Domains und IPs und dies und das und jenes und privat hatte ich das jetzt länger nicht mehr so in diesem Umfang so mal wieder Zones definieren und das war schön. Das hat richtig Spaß gemacht. Ich habe ja beruflich so mit Docker und Cloud und diesem ganzen neuen Zirkus zu tun, wo du maximal weit weg bist von genau diesen feinen Stellschrauben, wo du auf irgendwelche Interfaces angewiesen bist oder irgendwelche abstrakten Jammel-Formate, die dir irgendwie deine Maschinen definieren, aber nie in dem Detail es erlauben, wie du es gerne vielleicht hättest. Direkt am nackten Metall, also das nackte Metall ist ja auch schon einige Abstraktions-Ebenen hoch, aber so Internet hat man dann gefühlt noch an den Fingerspitzen ein bisschen. Ein bisschen Internetstaub.
Deutlich, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, ich meine halt die Leute, die dann noch so hier Kai oder so, die dann noch mit den BGP-Routen umherspielen und die Perienkabel romantisch bei Kerzenschein einstecken.
Der sagt ja immer, TCP hat da nichts mit zu tun, das ist ja Payload.
Ja, manche bewegen halt nur die Eiswürfel im Glas, andere sind halt so mit Eisbergen unterwegs und ganz andere bewegen Schollen.
Einen In-Inside, den ich jetzt noch hatte, dadurch, dass ich jetzt mein DNS wieder selber in der Hand hab, da benutze ich übrigens NSD. Und da hatte er jetzt auch mal wieder ein bisschen Statistiken und als ich so angefangen hab mit DNS rumzuspielen, auch in der Uni da so richtig, da fand ich ja auch das immer interessant, wenn man da, als ich dann IPv6 angemacht hab, so zu gucken, na wie ist denn so der Anteil von überhaupt IPv6 Queries. Und das war damals natürlich alles noch ein bisschen schmal mittlerweile. Jetzt, ich hab das einige Tage laufen lassen, sind 100.000 Queries IPv4 und 50.000 IPv6.
20.000 kommen ja schon, wenn du einmal Spiegel aufrufst.
20.000 kommen ja nicht so viele.
Wenn du auf meinem Nameserver für meine Domain klickst, du meinst jetzt nur die, die deine Domain fragen, nicht als Resolver und so.
Genau. Also das wird auch mehr.
Alles nur Roboter.
Alles nur Bots.
Aber Ende ist wirklich so, die Bots werden sich alle gegenseitig selber unterhalten, wie wir schon gesehen haben. Sie werden sogar miteinander telefonieren und wir liegen einfach an der Sonne, hoffe ich, und werden uns gut gehen lassen und sagen, lass die mal machen.
Na, aber die Moral von der Geschichte macht man ja selber, Leute.
Auf jeden Fall, vor allem macht es auch voll Spaß.
Dezentralisierung, Deplatformisierung, Eigenbestimmung.
Ja, in dem Spannungsverhältnis ist auch das Thema, was du gerade von der Liste gelöscht hast. Ich hab mir das nämlich angeguckt.
Was denn?
Dieser komische Service, lobe.ai. Die haben leider außer der Webseite noch nicht allzu viel zu bieten. Ich hab da Join Beta geklickt, aber keinen Invalid bekommen bis jetzt. Insofern ist es eigentlich auch kein Thema, weil es gibt nichts zu reden.
Das dachte ich mir nämlich auch.
Von der Idee her ist es halt sehr spannend, dass jemand quasi AI als Service macht und dass du in einem relativ einfach gehaltenen Interface deine AI-Blöcke zusammenklicken kannst. Wenn man ein bisschen mehr guckt, was sie da machen, ist vieles davon sind aber vortrainierte Netze.
Ja klar, das kann auch nur funktionieren. Um vielleicht mal den Leuten zu erklären, die jetzt nicht wissen, wovor wir reden. lobe.ai ist ein Service, der quasi die Power von Machine Learning und Neural Networks, wo wir jetzt auch schon ein bisschen über gesprochen haben, hier, also quasi dieses Durchtrainieren von Daten, um letztlich immer Aussagen darüber treffen zu können, was ist das oder ist das richtig, ist das falsch, je nachdem, was man da so trainiert, quasi so eine Bibliothek bereitzustellen und dafür im Web auch noch ein User Interface, um dann eben verschiedene Erkennungsketten miteinander zu verknüpfen und so ein Workflow herzustellen. Das ist schon irgendwie ganz interessant. Ich glaube auch, dass das durchaus Zukunft hat, ob es jetzt der Dienst konkret ist oder so, aber ich denke, dieses ganze Herstellen von Erkennungsketten und so, da gibt es durchaus auch End-User-Anwendungen in gewisser Hinsicht, die jetzt nicht nur jetzt von Developern selber durchgeführt werden, sondern dieses, ich trainiere mir mal mein eigenes Modell auf meinen eigenen Kram, das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen. Von irgendwie, ich erkenne meine eigene Katze und dann geht die Katzenklappe nur auf, wenn es meine Katze ist, bis hin zu ähnlich gelagerten Sachen. Ob das dann groß gewährt hat, weiß ich noch nicht, aber das wird auf jeden Fall kommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schon erwähnt habe, ich habe ein bisschen mit Kaffee mal rumgespielt. Das ist eins der, neben TensorFlow, eins der beiden großen AI-Machine-Learning-Frameworks für diesen ganzen neuronalen Kram. Und es ist mega schmerzhaft. Also das Teil überhaupt zu installieren. Also das ist ein Gefricke ohne Ende. Und dann sind da Beispiele dabei. Und wenn du dann was eigenes machen willst, dann besteht das Beispiel daraus, dass du anfängst, Skripte und anderen Kram aus den Beispielen rauszukopieren. Weil da nämlich alle pfadehart verdrahtet sind in Skripte, die in den Beispielen drin sind. Also es ist wirklich ganz schlimm. Und das ist natürlich, wenn du jetzt da so Kisten hast, die du mit Linien verbindest und kannst Parameter einstellen und so weiter, kannst du sagen, jetzt mach mal schön. Das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich was ganz anderes. Das eröffnet natürlich viel, viel mehr Leuten dieses Machine-Learning-Field. Aber mit diesen Python-Skripten und so, das geht halt gar nicht.
Das hat so ein bisschen was von Physik-Baukasten. Also du kriegst da irgendwie so ein Toolset und dann kannst du da so ein paar Sachen, so Elektronik-Baukasten, wo du so deine Kabel hast, ein paar ICs drin hast, so deine Logik-Gatter, so My First Nand-Gatter zusammenbauen. Und hier ist es halt auch so, ja, da hast du halt dann Fotos und dann matchest du es halt auf ein Smiley, also auf ein Emoticon, auf ein Emoji und so ne Sachen. Aber es sind auch schon ein paar pfiffige Sachen drin, so mit wo wird drauf gezeigt im Gesicht. Und ist alles jetzt nichts, was einen jetzt groß vom Hocker wirft, wenn man sich ein bisschen mit der Technologie schon beschäftigt hat, was sie theoretisch ja alles kann und die Technologie fährt Autos und macht irgendwie andere Wurenzeug und bombardiert bestimmt auch schon irgendwelche Gebiete auf diesem Planeten. Das kann dann bald jeder zuhause vom...
Ja, das ist...... Mal ganz ehrlich, das, was die da machen, ist Lego Mindstorms. Wenn du versuchst, das mit dem...
Oh, das ist auch ein sehr guter Vergleich. Das war vielleicht das, was ich suchte.
Wenn du das mit dem Café-Framework versuchst, dann bist du schon direkt bei AliExpress und versuchst irgendwie Bauteile zusammenzukaufen, wo du noch nicht mal ein richtiges Datenblatt für hast. Also, weißt du, so stark ist der Unterschied. Und irgendwas dazwischen wär ganz nett, wo ich nicht irgendwie mich um alles kümmern muss, aber irgendwie auch trotzdem die Möglichkeiten hab. ja...
Interessantes Experiment auf jeden Fall.
Ich hab übrigens in der Zwischenzeit noch diese andere Mail-Tester-Dings gefunden. unlocktheinbox.com/mailminustester. Für alle die, die Monate später fragen, ey, du hattest doch mal in der Freak Show irgendwas erzählt. Jetzt finde ich es aber nicht mehr.
War das Thema mit dem normalen Net? War man da jetzt schon fertig?
Ich möchte es noch mal kurz nachtragen.
Verlenken kannst.
Werde ich tun. Aber wir sind durch, ne?
Also wenn ich für den Lobe eine Einladung kriege und damit mal rumgespielt habe, dann können wir das Thema nochmal aufgreifen. Ich glaube, vorher gibt es nichts zu reden.
Genau. Interessante Technologie.
Und Lenny, bist du noch wach? Du bist aus.
Du musst auf deinen Knopf drücken.
Die muss man drücken.
Das haben wir vorher, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Folgen mal besprochen. Und die Folge erhielt dann auch den Titel über State redet man nicht, State hat man.
Das geht nach wie vor.
Weil irgendwie dieses Mischpult nicht sagt, ob der Mute-Button jetzt an ist oder nicht. Ja, aber wenn du da draufdrückst, dann schickt er nochmal ein Mute. Und wenn du loslässt, wieder ein Unmute. Und dann ist der Button eben wieder gern muted.
Das heißt, so viel State hat er gar nicht. Weil sonst würde er sich das ja merken, dass vorher aus war.
Ein Bit ist ein Bit.
Okay, lass uns nicht so viel über State reden. Unser Zustand ist fortgeschritten. So viel kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Alles klar, das war's. Freak Show 217.
Kurz nach Mittag nach fertig. Das hatten wir lange nicht.
Dass wir schon so zeitig fertig sind.
Wenn Huckel da ist.
Dann fassen wir uns kurz.
Tschüss.